what is popping everybody and welcome to
the mix black voices and gaming day 2
where we are celebrating amazing black
game developers
from all over the world i'm your host
justin woodward co-founder of the mix
the media indie exchange and indie team
and terra bang entertainment i'm also a
proud advisor
on the humble black game developer fund
but that's enough about me
i want to introduce my co-host alfonso
hooker
what's up everybody it's alfonso hooker
i'm representing uh tech perfect and
game heads game heads is a uh
youth of color uh game development
organization so we teach you the color
game development skills and devops
skills and i'm just
so happy to be here yeah shout out to
gameheads we're gonna have some folks on
um
later uh in the show a brief history
about black voices in gaming we started
this back in june of 2020
uh during the gorilla collective and
when the protests and demonstrations
were happening that united us from all
around the world yeah we're we're in
oakland we're in berkeley right now in
the bay area and there's a lot of
activism out here and was it was pretty
crazy so
uh during the guerrilla collective we
teamed up with raw fury
who helped to sponsor the first event
gamespot twitch ign were some awesome
folks
uh who helped with the cause um and and
we continue that momentum
this time with some other amazing
sponsors so we can't
um thank you enough first off uh
one of the sponsors which i'm a part of
like i said and we'll be talking to site
later
is humble games with the black game
developer fund if you're a black game
developer
and you're looking for some prototype
funding or possibly publishing
please follow the link below yeah hit
them up
so you could be a part of that and we
also have some
other amazing sponsors hopping in of
course raw fury if it wasn't from raw
fury's contribution from
the first event this wouldn't happen
playstation jumped in big time again
humble games kickstarter we love you and
we are streaming on razer's equipment um
we have
a amazing show coming up but let's go to
our first
guest sean alexander allen who will be
showcasing
treachery in beat down city roll the
trailer
[Music]
yeah yeah they call me when ninja people
attack the street
my president's black and y'all gon give
them back to me
i spend half the week training and doing
tournaments
i spawn with gang bangers with janky
shuriken yeah
it's too late now you by the chances bro
your hands is low got a hail and
ambulance to go
this ain't no slap boxing we don't
pretend to scuffle
i make the whole book and still will
bend a couple
i fight like big companies over business
struggles
or anime heroes do when they friends in
trouble
and ain't gotta be noble i fight for
stupid reasons
i find a reason to fight against any
human breathing
if i'm on your block you need to tell a
doctor
i'm hella big and i'm about to punch a
helicopter i'm super roasting my eyes
open
don't provoke when i'm side scrolling
street sweeper peacekeeper
two cellulous three people you dignified
with a simple mind and that cash got you
all hypnotized
laptop and no indesign so they don't
watch what they gentrify yeah
[Music]
yo the beatdown city uh that song is
is slapping the beat is banging the
lyrics are super dope
it's hilarious we got sean on the line
and we're gonna
actually play um alfonzo's gonna be
driving for most of the time
and we're gonna play through the game
what is up sean how is it going
what's up man how you doing yeah dude
like we were talking about this before
like everything is on point culturally
with the game obviously but like how did
uh
how did you get started let's go a
little bit back into your history
uh i mean
it's a uh it's funny um
i remember going like i wanted to do
comics as a kid
actually and um like i really loved
comics i had like how to draw marvel
comics
or how to draw comics the marvel way and
made a ton of comics and never really
actually owned video games but you could
you know get comics
and uh um i don't know something kind of
flipped in me i i even made a comic that
was
set in a fictional video game world
where all the characters
were drawn like i drew everybody in like
jagged
like pixel art style but by hand with
pen and marker
[Music]
and then you know just i one day i got
into my head because i kept getting
discouraged for doing all the things i
wanted to do like
writing music uh
all these various things that were just
kept away from me and then one day i was
like i'm gonna make video games
and i didn't let a single person
discourage me from that no matter what
it was like the last thing that i was
like no we're doing this
and uh i was actually talking about
recently that i was like a moderator on
ign's message boards around
2000 to 2007 wow
i did not know that that's that's good
yeah i
also sort of used to troll on those
boards too simultaneously which i don't
know how that worked
uh um and i went to my first e3
i was just saying i went to my first e3
when i was without in 2003 actually
wow were you like were you working at a
uh like a game stop or something when
you went to e3 for the first time
yeah that because like you could used to
build a go if you were an eb games
employee or game celebrity i was eb
games
like i used to hang out at my eb games
wanting to get a job there
uh in 2000 and they just didn't it was
hard to get a job at these stores
um especially if you were in school like
i was
and then i was just talking about this
with my wife i actually got into
i got my eb games job the day that spice
city came out
oh wow that's great and um yeah
and also got another job the day that
that same week
which meant now i'm doing double work
while going to school full-time
and i was just like i've been hurting i
hadn't had a steady job
in years i've been trying to get it but
no one wanted to hire a student
and my friend who was the assistant
manager of the store
uh he got promoted a manager the manager
got moved to another store
and the manager was actually this like
racist ass italian dude
um who just didn't want to hire any more
black people
[Music]
and so when he left second manager
how did you get into your first gig did
you go to school for
for game design or art and design
uh i went to school yeah i went to
school for graphic design and then
kind of hated my department and so i
went to uh
uh so then i switched to computer art
which was like i was really into like
3d and stuff like that and then that was
so time intensive especially since i had
a full-time job that i
ended up doing more 2d animation
and the 2d animation mixed with 3d for
my thesis
and then after i graduated
a few months afterwards i applied to a
bunch of jobs that were all drying up
and eventually rockstar posted a
game capture position which i had never
known existed to make trailers
what is game and what is it like what do
you do
when you're game capturing
uh it's for that job it's complicated
because like you know a 3d game
you know when you see trailers right and
you see like someone like
jump off a roof with an explosion
happening behind them
uh that could be fully animated uh like
a company like blur and those trailers
cost like a million dollars a pop or at
least
to make or you could have a fully game
play trailer where
there's a person playing the game
running the person
off and jumping off the thing and then
there's another person
filming it as it goes down so that's
kind of a combination of those two and
as
as i was did it more and more i started
doing whole trailers by myself
oh wow where i'd be holding two
controllers i'd like hold
forward you'd pause the game hold
forward play the game at like 25
speed and then put a rubber band around
the controller to make the person keep
running forward
and then like press a button like this
and take the camera
and like just like
move the camera like that as the
person's falling off the roof or
something
yeah that's that's super interesting so
when you uh
after so you worked at rockstar for a
little bit and then during
while you're at rockstar is that when
you started treachery
in a sense uh it was an idea um
because when i was at rockstar i saw
stuff like super meat boy
come out and uh and i was just like oh
like indie games are a thing and uh
it's funny because i had a friend who
was really into cave story
and i didn't get into cave story then
but when i saw super meat boy on xbox
live i was like oh
like and parade and i was like oh these
games can come out and you can do stuff
so i kind of started talking to like my
hr and i was like what if i wanted to
make like a mobile game
and he could actually never answer my
question so i just kind of started
just coming up with an idea of story and
a world
uh and character designs that i didn't
know were going to go anywhere
and then in 2012 uh the same year that
uh like i kind of wanted to work on the
game more and there was a bit of a
thing that happened then there was a
split with rockstar and i went full-time
to work on the game for a bit
yeah i remember playing the game you
know early on when we because we met the
first time at evo
2012 or was it 2013 when we met when we
were working
with carmel man and uh and i just saw
the game and i fell in love with it just
because it's a mashup of
you know a brawler and it has these rpg
elements can you can you talk about like
uh your influences for for making this
game
yeah uh uh like i kind of always tell
people um
part of that indie scene thing going on
was like castle crashers was a big game
but then we also saw
like the rebirth we saw a double dragon
the arcade game which i had never played
before it only played the nintendo
version
and turtles the arcade game which i'd
also never played before i only played
the nintendo version
um but like those games were coming back
and i was not a fan of castle crashers
um i didn't like how castle crashers was
um very uh
character action focused like it was
like doing all of the like
juggling and everything from uh like a
devil may cry and you know like they
have like spells you could cast to
launch people in the air and knock them
in the air and
i like i like down and dirty i like down
and dirty bunch of people in the face of
the streets
right like so like uh
and also like i kind of had seen how
like the
i don't know like urban games like game
set in a city
just kind of disappeared from the
landscape and uh
so i was like i want to make the best
beat em up ever
and we started working in game maker
like i actually was the first person to
lay down code in the game and game maker
like i had brad in the game and i made a
move up down and left
right and uh the programmer nico
uh hadn't 100 but taking it seriously
like we've been talking about working on
the game but then it was like oh
if sean if i don't start working on it
sean's going to leave me behind so then
we started like kind of like weekly
um weekly working on it and then
yeah and then like it we hit a point
where we were not liking what was going
on and i was kind of freaking out
and i was uh and i literally had a
shower moment where i was i went
took a shower that night it was very sad
uh
and i was like
let's make it turn based like i was like
because i like had this confluence
of mario or a beach i'm like i like rpgs
i like mario rpg
i like fallouts bats i like hybrid
heaven which
only a small handful of people know
about and
which is basically like a fighting game
rpg they're very different than this
and so then that's when we went to work
and started figuring that out and that
was just
that was just it was a lot of it was a
lot of work but it was so much more
interesting than what we were trying to
do
that i was just like yeah let's do that
and
we got our first build that was like a
playable that people could see like the
real ideas
and it was uh i think it was like brad
or lisa versus
three john's and it was like the idea of
whether or not
you could make this game feel like a
good fighting game
and that was when we were like oh yeah
we got this so let's keep going
so what were some of the the challenges
that you had as an indie
developer as a black indie developer as
you were going through the process was
it
like was the was the development five
years
or like what was the development period
and what were some of the challenges you
had as a
as a black developer um i mean
2012 is when i left rockstar and this
game came out last year
yeah so that's that's uh eight
years plus r d essentially
um i'd say it was kind of like a decade
in the making
uh but i mean
um like i didn't know how to make
like it's weird like i worked at
rockstar i had worked on
like i've been able to basically
see and play and touch games that were
nowhere near
like that were very early like i like
like i got to like touch grand theft
auto 5 like when it
where where if you walked tudor steps in
any direction you'd fall off the face of
the map like so i got to see games like
at a very early stage
and i but i didn't know like what it was
like to make a game when there was
literally nothing on screen
right so and my programmer also we were
both very new to it
and i didn't have good uh project
management skills
i thought i did um i
i don't know like i thought i like i had
worked in qa for a bit i thought i
knew it didn't it uh so it was like a
lot of like having to learn how to
be a developer was a major thing also
like
finding money for this idea that i'm
working on was very difficult
like i thankfully you know was a part of
the playstation mobile
bit which was like you know shane bent
housing likes
like basically helped me
[Music]
work on this because i wouldn't have
been able to work on it without
some money so that's a key thing but
like playstation mobile development was
fraught with technical issues
just because the sdk was terrible
basically any
places your mobile dev would tell you
that
and um you know just
i've i've pitched to a million people to
try to help get funding
and you know i had to go back to
full-time work
and just you know really had to like
[Music]
i don't know like
like anything i had i poured right back
into this game
and you know there's been some benefits
like you know the industry came out with
the kickstarter
and backed the game and you know that
was amazing
um so at the same time we asked for way
too little money
yeah no i mean i feel that and uh so you
basically had to become
learn how to become more of a producer
um you had to get your entrepreneurship
up and like that type of thing how did
you like maneuver through these things
did you
did you have uh mentors or folks to help
you out through the because this is a
it's a ridiculous process if you don't
have folks to
to work with you know what i mean
[Music]
yeah uh that's that's what i was saying
like with kickstarter i really say that
the industry is why this game it's
like you know i kind of started going to
you know my first e3 was 2003
and then i didn't go back until i was at
rockstar and when i was at rockstar i
basically
was able to i went to e3 and uh
um you know i had a little bit more you
know
uh what was it confidence you know and i
got to talk to people
and but i think i was real easy to deal
with and i
uh made a lot of friends and um
it was very nice to a lot of people a
lot of people very nice back
and that led to when i wanted to go do
my own thing
i remember this guy seth skysel who used
to be the
the video games writer at new york times
i met him at a halo party
that i wouldn't have been able to get
into without being a rock star person
because i
uh it was a weird thing of handing in a
rockstar
business card and then letting me in
because of that like it was strange
because those like microsoft parties
were very exclusive
and i had no invites to anything and um
i was in there and seth was just talking
to me and i was like talking to him
about how i wanted to go indy
and do that and he was just like yeah
man that sounds great seth's also a
black dude
writing about games so that was really
cool to run meet him
and then we were at this party and he
introduced me to like phil harrison
and like all these other people in the
games industry that were just there
because it was a
very exclusive party and he was just
like yo this is sean
former rock star like he's a rock star
right now he wants to go be an indie
blah blah and those guys all just being
like
oh that sounds cool like yeah you should
totally do that and you know just
having that bit of that bit of like
encouragement even if they barely know
who i am and someone just
bigging me up already in front of people
was like pretty nice to be like oh yeah
i should do that also
i was at a party where i met a bunch of
like my heroes like i met like nathan
vela from who was
one of the founders of cappy and uh my
friend baru who was one of the
he was like the lead engineer on skulls
of the shogun before it had a name like
you know early indie title
yeah yeah i met suda51 and a bunch of
people at this party
and so i got to see what being an indie
developer was like also
so it was like and then so those were
people i could also email
and ask for help and advice and it just
kept growing from there
and uh yeah i mean like just
having people to keep to talk to like
when i was like
just feeling or feeling like a failure
and just seeing like i feel like a
failure like what's up and they're like
nah man don't worry about it like you
know when you gotta push your game back
three or four
times yeah and having people say you
gotta do what's best for you sean
like that was always super helpful it's
very yeah it feels like very
serendipitous
in that way and you're also you're also
one of the co-founders of game devs of
color
expo like can you talk about how that
kind of came about
while you're developing the game
[Music]
yeah um so i am not a co-founder i'm a
co-organizer
oh okay okay i'd say i sort of helped
found it in the sense that
uh i've one day i
just woke up in 2012 that was part of my
2012 awakening was like um
i just had this flip in my brain where i
was like
i always say it was because i started
listening to dead prez and saul williams
and their music's very revolutionary
and i started looking around and being
like there's no black people in the
games industry
and so then like i started like really
and then i i wrote a big
talk about it for indycade of 2013 which
had me diving into like you know the
history of hip-hop and tech
and just getting into all these stats
and
looking at all this stuff and that
got me i became just i was like this
like hyper radicalized person who was
just like really fighting for this
and so i started just trying to find all
the black folks
that were in games industry and go talk
to them
and figure out like what we could do to
go forward and i found kat
on twitter because she was friends with
a mutual friend and then she was
teaching
uh cat small she she is the founder with
uh with uh chris algoo they have their
company brooklyn gamery
and i found cat and i went to a ux talk
she was giving just so i could meet her
in person
and i just this is what i do is i find
black folks in the industry and i start
talking to them about like
how can we make the industry better how
you know just whispering like hey you
know there's no black folks blah blah
and
based on those conversations a lot of
times people like will just become
friends and tied together forever like
that's what happened with me and you
uh at evo right we just started talking
about you know there's no black people
here so
and then cat just the talking from there
because cat is an amazing organizer
she helped found code liberation which
was a group for teaching women how to
code
and so she's just like this amazing
person for organization and so she
worked with chris
to found game joseph color expo as like
this just kind of this
idea of like is there a market for this
and it was at microsoft in times square
they had they gave up
some free space for a lot of game events
and it was pretty big it was great and
then she reached out to me and some
other folks
the next year and said i want
to do more i need help and i had gone to
the
schomburg center for the black comic
book festival and saw in a bunch of
other events and saw how
dope this like spy in harlem was like a
very pro-black space
and i said we need to move the event
there so i did stuff for the event like
i made some big moves for it because i'm
i'm just
i always say i'm kind of like the you
know like
malcolm x or stokely carmichael type of
the games industry and that like i'm
just like let's change everything right
now as much as possible so
i got like it's super dope what you like
uh what has come come up with the game
devs of color expo
can you tell us about like um where
you're going with new challenger
and you have treachery and beatdown city
it has like a diverse
cast you're an activist you're doing all
this cool stuff what's next for a new
challenger
i mean the next big thing is we're just
still we're supporting this game right
now
that's like the only real thing i could
talk about i got other things in the
works but
you know until things get uh
yeah until well until things just get
more you know i'm
i always talk about how i come from like
i grew up in poverty
so for me until something is happening
it's not happening
in a lot of ways i can't really 100
believe it it's like you can't believe
there's money coming until it's in your
pocket
yeah so what's what's next for treachery
do you have an update coming or anything
yeah we're going to have a there's this
big story well right now we have a
localization patch that we're actually
going to be putting into
cert very soon that has a bunch of
languages to get it out to a more
global scale it's going to come out in
europe and australian
australia and we're also working with a
japanese publisher for that
and then we have this massive patch
which is going to be
like the size of the game as it is right
now
for story wise and more enemies and
content and stuff
and it's probably not the wisest thing
to do but
it's gonna be like free for everybody
who has the game that's dope so where
can we find the game
and follow you yeah i can find the game
yeah uh there's yeah under uh beatdown
underscore city on twitter
uh a new challenger new challenger with
a u
n huge challenger on twitter
and there's just beatdowncity.com
yo i appreciate you i mean we stay up
late nights just talking about all this
stuff
like all your activism like definitely
rubbed off on me
like you're a cohort in my eyes man i
love you everything you do
uh thank you for jumping on the show we
appreciate it love the game brother
it's i i play all the time at home so
it's dope
it's good to see you again yeah thank
you so much
knows a little bit about what the future
is yeah he does yeah he does
all right thanks sean all right i
appreciate it all right thank you
yeah i wanna that's treachery and
beatdown city yes
uh the game is really dope the the
combination of rpg elements and a beat
em up is really cool i want to shout out
steam
actually and valve because they hooked
us up with a page
all the games that are showcased today
or a majority of them
you can wish list them you can either
purchase them or wish list them
and that and just show these developers
love because
it definitely helps um and that's what
we're trying to do support black game
developers and that is what steam is
doing today
next up we have another amazing game
this developer is actually in uh the
humble black game developer fund as well
and it we're going to go to adam karim
with proto droid delta next and this is
proto-droid
delta let's roll the trailer i
am delta a proto-joint
[Music]
[Music]
so you're another prototype like me que
mo
nantes i always assumed i was the only
one you cannot allow the worthless lives
of a few gang leaders
to jeopardize the safety of thousands of
civilians
life and death isn't yours to decide we
will find another way
in order to win i must go stronger
your blade is looking weak come vamos i
will teach you my two rules
she will be the change
[Applause]
and that is the action platformer delta
on the line we have
adam kareem what is up adam how's it
going
what's going on it's great yo it's great
seeing you again man
you're like one of the most enthusiastic
people in general that i've ever met
i'm nuts man i don't know what it is i
just love people i love
uh i love making games which is like a
hobby of mine
um i don't know i feel like it's easier
for me to be hype
because i just like uh like generally
speaking so like yeah i'm hyped now
it'll be harder for me to tone it down
than it is so i just go with the easy
route
and i see you like post in the in the
discord channel something oh my god
adam's back
you like making me reinvigorated while
i'm like grinding because yesterday was
you know we had a long stream yesterday
i was like oh my god right
figure this out when we're jumping on
i'm gonna be on here with adam but
um we're gonna play proto droid delta
now i'm just gonna
yeah yeah tell us about the game i mean
it's been an interesting journey
yeah so like it started off um as just a
desire to see a good 3d mega man
um and because like i think i always
loved like mega man x is my favorite
game ever
um and i always like kind of suck just
just one second let's get you on the
stream real quick okay sure
there we go yeah so i almost thought it
was kind of lame that
i was always inspired by the idea of
making like a 3d mega man that played
really well
because like that hasn't been done
there's like 30 2d 2d games
and then like other franchises which
made a good jump like mario
zelda metroid i was like yo this should
be a good
3d platformer mega man um that was like
the original inspiration
um and uh and i just kind of took it
from there man
yes i mean you could definitely see the
inspiration um
and you did some some other prototypes
which i think that's fascinating a lot
of uh you know developers starting off
like how do i start off and like you did
it the perfect way can you
explain some of that yeah dude that's
actually where it started um it actually
didn't start with mega man my game dev
journey i started out wanting to make a
sonic fan game like a 3d sonic game that
played really well
and so i was like yeah man like it'd be
great if sonic could like have
a 3d game um and then that kind of like
started the bug was that like this
belief that i could somehow create a
good 3d sonic
so i entered my first fan game into uh
sage the sonic amateur game expo
and it did okay it was called sonic
explorers um and then from there i was
like well let me go to like the next
franchise that i've loved so much
um let me do mega man and so this game
actually started as a mega man x
uh 3d platformer prototype called like
mega man x and zero training missions
where you can either play as x or you
could play a zero
and um and so and then at some point i
was like you know what like i'm spending
hours making this game every night after
work and
and hanging out that like i should like
make it something unique and make it its
own and so that's when the idea for like
trying to get into proto droid it
came to life yeah what was your initial
what was your initial day job while you
were working on these like these really
quiet sites
yeah man when i started i used to work
at whirlpool designing home appliances
i'm a mechanical engineer by trade i
still work full time
and so i just play i just i make i do
games as a side um it's like
a hobby so that's kind of like the way
i've been managing things um
actually one quick thing about the game
so alfonso it's like an auto lock
mechanic
whenever you point the camera in the
general direction of an enemy it will
lock onto it so you can shoot them
and and it'll automatically shoot at the
target um
the other thing i want to tell you is if
you press the right if you press and
hold the right trigger when she's on the
ground she'll do a dash
there you go and if you combine that
with a jump you can get like really
crazy distances because like
anyone who's playing mega man x that's
like the core mechanic it's like dash
jumping and dashing a lot
so i really put a lot of effort into
trying to like retain the feel of that
because that's really important like a
mega man x game yeah let's just go into
the mechanics let's just talk about the
game in general
yeah dude so like for me the biggest
challenge is like how do you
make a 3d mega man that doesn't become
like a third person shooter
this is a very different skill set from
like game design wise
for someone who's used to just like
pressing buttons versus managing two
sticks
right and so it's like i didn't want to
alienate folks who were
you know like myself like who more into
the platforming elements of it
and that's what the genius about the
mega man games is that like you just
have to jump and shoot those are the
only commands really
so i was like how can i how can i like
capture that how can i like jump and
shoot
in a 3d environment and that's where the
soft lock on came on where like
originally i had the camera kind of like
focus on
the target but it became disorienting
for a player to like gauge your jumps
when the camera is also moving the
entire time
so i was like let me instead let the
camera be alone and just have like
through coding like be smart about who
you're locked on
so the players always keep their spatial
awareness they can jump and shoot at the
same time
that's definitely you could definitely
see that reflected in
in the gameplay for sure it feels super
solid i know you were really paying
attention to those mechanics
sorry bonzo got smashed up and he was
practicing last night too for sure he's
like yo
let me get that game like send me a link
to the game because i need to practice
and not look like an ass while i'm
playing
but he's doing he's doing exactly what i
said yes
he's doing really well though so far
um go ahead
no it's going to self on so um one thing
you can do is if you press and hold the
shoot button
you can hold you can store a charge shot
and those destroy shields immediately
um and so when you deal with those
turrets the technique is either
um you you rush up and engage them and
take them out with like your melee
attack
or you break because the melee break
shields or you break your shield from
the distance with her charger shot
and then they become kind of exposed so
that's what i'm trying to do game design
wise is like
you have to give players a reason to
like to use each tool you know what i'm
saying and i'm taking a lot of cues from
like doom eternal how they're really
smart about like yeah each weapon is a
tool
and every encounter with an enemy is
more like solving a problem than it is
about just like
your ability to shoot really fast yeah
that's still
you have like a super diverse cast of
characters and that was very apparent in
your kickstarter
can you uh kind of dive into that
yeah man um so it's like when i had the
opportunity to like make a game and
create a world
i kind of wanted to make something that
reflects more the world that i grew up
in
because like you know what you see a lot
in gaming is that like stick the mega
man franchise for example
there's over like 30 games and all the
characters are of the same skin tone for
the most part and then
additionally the majority guys you know
what i'm saying it's like in over 30
games you can count on one hand the
number of female characters
who are almost always in some sort of
support role not necessarily heroes
or really significant um and then you
have like all
the heroes with the same skin tone and
and i get that in a sense that like
people tend to create things that they
can see themselves in you know they
create things in their own image so when
games are made
mostly by like japanese developers or
like the same
folks in like in the us you know white
folks or whatnot um you know the great
work characters that reflect
their their upbringing so i was like
well i got a chance to do the same for
me
you know like i can create characters
that look like the people i grew up in
so there's like
four i think there's a total of five
black characters in the cast there's
three latino characters
um i really wanted to be like a
celebration of like the true
diversity of gamers as a whole you know
it's like it's great to have more games
that look more like the people that play
them
um one thing i joke about a lot is that
like super smash bros right
as like super smash also has like over
75
characters in the roster and there's
like more furries and animals and
they're all like black or brown
characters
yeah and it's in a lot of ways like a
reflection of like over 30 years
of like gaming icons and gaming history
and in 30 years
you know we got more furries and then
like black folks and if they are
they either bad guys like ganondorf or
they're like just an alternative skin so
i was like yo i can make a game
yeah go ahead i was just gonna say or
mad ambiguous
like mad and big like yeah like mine and
commando the new buying commando or
you know what i mean yeah man it's both
like you know i want to create something
that like players like myself growing up
can like see themselves in because
they currently aren't a lot of options
like that um and so things are getting
better you know we got things like
horizon zero dawn the female league
control
um like strong female lead um and you've
got like more diversity in the cast of
like other games
but you know we're moving along but
we're not quite there and so that's why
i made a point for my game
yeah i really dig that you you uh added
that to the game for sure your
personality because i wanted to see that
too as a kid and even now like
where am i represented in this besides
like to create your own character type
scenario right right so you did a
kickstarter
um and can you just talk a little bit
about like
like how you started development and
kind of move through development and
then you're also part of the
um the humble black game developer fun
yeah can you talk about that experience
so uh i guess i'll start with um i guess
i'll start with the kickstarter because
not a lot of people have done a
kickstarter um
they're super hard they are super hard
um especially if you do it alone i
pretty much managed my kickstarter on my
own at first
eventually i hired help for like
marketing and to run ads which has been
significant and tremendous but the
reason i ran the kickstarter was because
like you know
i do games as a hobby and i felt kind of
like
i really wanted to see number one is it
like a market for a game like this
um but number two i wanted to see if
there's a way i can help to sort of like
offset the expenses
since i'm paying for all these things
myself you know uh i kind of felt guilty
like you know
everyone has a hobby you know but like
um if i kind of bad spending like too so
much on like personal hobby um for my
family and whatnot
so i thought a kickstarter might be a
good way to kind of like you know bridge
that
gap um and it was super difficult but in
the end it was really awesome because
like
it showed me that people really like a
game like this and and people
really like this idea because i was like
let me get an early read about like
the viability of this you know like
maybe this if you know maybe it's not
that interesting to people but instead
the response is really strong
um and then so what was the follow-up
question
oh i was just saying yeah the
kickstarter it's like you you have this
journey right prototyping then you build
proto droid then you do a kickstarter
and now you're a part of the humble
black game developer fund like what is
what has been your
uh experience uh with that program
man humble's been fantastic these folks
have made like again taking such a large
load off my shoulders because like
with the kickstarter like it was hopeful
the goal was just offset the expenses as
best i could but it didn't really cover
the full game's budget
uh at least as i projected it out um so
getting the support from
humble's been amazing because now it's
like enables me to go get higher quality
talent higher quality 3d artists
high quality animators um because i'm
working primarily with myself
and doing most of the pretty much all
the coding and the game design
and like the world building and such but
i'm leveraging a lot like three
artists to help with the design my main
2d illustrator who does all the like the
helps of the character design
and without them like this stuff doesn't
happen you know so like um
and so the ability to like not like to
be able to get good talent
is is really really helpful really
really helpful
so when you were starting you were like
building the game you're building the
levels yourself kind of like
grey box style right and then you needed
to figure out how to
how to build it out and get your team
get a team um
jumping aboard can you describe a little
bit about that process because i think
developers who are um developer people
who want to be developers kind of
don't understand that process and it
would be interesting yeah dude
the most i can say is you gotta you
gotta make a prototype of something
you know what i'm saying because what
happens is like in making proto droid or
making like my fan games
i learned what i'm good at and what i'm
not good at and i learned like what i
like doing and what i don't like doing
um and then i was able to be more
focused about like what is a specific
help that i need to hire and like
what things do i want to focus on so
case in point i really love game design
i love
i like program mechanics programming ai
the stuff that makes a game playable
but i found for making my my favorite
games my strengths in the art department
were really weak and it was taking me a
ton of time to just like
get the lighting right for a level or or
set the right assets or just make a
level look believable
so by making those like those quick fan
games
i got to learn that about myself and it
became easier to build a team that way
plus like when you have something
playable you know i'm saying you have a
lot more
i'll call it like cred like people know
that like okay this guy doesn't just
have ideas
he can deliver and brings a lot to the
table him or herself and so
um and so that's been like an important
part of the journey oh sweet you got him
in the shields down
that was nice alfonso that was nice
um yeah i'm just like to the point of
game design there's very little of it
in this in this part of the game right
now this was like mostly like i created
it it's called like a zoo
i got this idea from forest dowling
who's like a really good
developer over at the molasses flood he
was a level designer for bioshock
infinite
um and now he runs his own game studio
and he was like you got to make a zoo
which is like
that's like your your small playable
space so you can quickly
like get a sense of the game feel and
things like that so that's what this
this this demo area sorted out as it's
just like a bunch of like random
platforming challenges
without much thought of like difficulty
scaling or or
or relative placement i was just like
okay how does this feel when you got a
bunch of stuff in front of you
so the difficulty spikes are all over
the place
um yeah
what what advice would you give
inspiring
uh young game developers who trying to
get into the game or not even young just
like
inspiring uh game developers
let me see advice i would get i would
say number one
um make a game as quick as you can i
know some people get really excited
about making an
engine or or trying to make like this
big grand big like space opera
like it has all their ideas you don't
want to make your first project your
most beloved one
right your first project has to be
something you're just learning from and
testing from
um because like you're gonna make a ton
of mistakes and you don't want that to
kind of be
like attached to the thing that you that
you care most about
um and so that's why for me like it was
fun to start with fan games
um because like i can like take those
learnings and put them in
um the other thing too is really make
leverage of like all the game engine
all the game developing tools like
unreal is free and the blueprint system
is incredible like i'm not a code like i
don't know c plus plus myself you know
like um yeah
i just you know but i've looked through
the blueprint system i'm able to like um
to create whole games without ever
writing a single line of code and so
it's been like
really really awesome um and so i think
being able to
basically remove the various or rotate
the camera around there you go
so being able to remove the barriers and
getting your game made
is is the best advice so that you can
start you know get to get a feel for
like
what am i good at what kind of games i
like to make and and how should i move
forward
i'm just checking it out a little bit
yeah man yeah
the the really big trick alfonzo if you
can work the timing is like the dash
jump
so it's like right trigger then a right
trigger then a and you become like this
like space ninja
yeah there you go she goes kind of nuts
man what other mechanics you have
in the game or do you have planned that
you can share
oh funny you should say that um i guess
i shouldn't do this on the stream
but like are you guys by computer yeah
of course you are you're playing on the
game okay um wait for a second
destroy this enemy and i'll tell you the
little secret okay um so
um someone hit left control three times
in a row
no no that so we have someone else who's
who's handling that that may not work
but
did you get oh god yeah there it is okay
you've now unlocked literally everything
so she has a double jump so if you jump
again in the air oh
you got to take care of that guy
there'll be a double jump you can
perform the dash in the air so if you
jump and then press dash
to perform that in the air there you go
and you can get like really crazy
distances with that
she also has um um different weapons so
press uh
y on the gamepad the top button i think
it is
now um hold the shoot button and there's
a machine gun oh
oh you shot the rocket launcher at close
range it's gonna mess you up but it
tells you which weapon you have equipped
at the bottom
um so the shotgun so you can fire that
it basically gives a wide spread
um when you fire it the idea i think i
want to make that like
like an effect where it will disable
enemies um so that
it becomes more of a strategic thing and
less like a damage spread because she
has damage spreading options
javelin is the most powerful shot in the
game it should cut through shields and
it travels a big distance
it's like the one but it takes up your
meter so if you see
all weapons share the same meter because
i really want to focus on like
strategic decisions like like quick
strategic decisions about what weapon am
i going to use what advantage do i get
from this weapon
while avoiding hazards and avoiding
lasers and avoiding people shooting at
you it's like like mega man you know you
you've always been thinking on your feet
playing mega man
um the other thing she has are more
blade attacks so
if you go um go to a flat like get past
this hazard and you can and you can kind
of see them more easily
um because there's different moves you
can do with her blade oh i can get past
this you gotta jump
okay so hold hold the left trigger oh
yeah
you already have it unlock the dash
unlock so so hold the left trigger
and then you'll see the button mapping
for the different blade special she has
so if you press um like a she'll do her
vertical one which is ideal for taking
out
um enemies who are above you in a single
shot and then if you
if you press like square it it performs
like
um a wave that she'll shoot out and it
also is like the single
strongest like blade strike so if anyone
is directly in front of you it kills
uh knocks them out oh that's the dash
that one is for closing
uh great distances very quickly and then
that's the spin you're kind of inspired
by like um like like links on
um spin attack and legend of zelda now
that one yeah i have to work on that
special effect so it looks more powerful
but that's the strongest attack in the
game um currently um
so yeah this is uh what they thought you
can unlock
yeah yeah it's cool to see that like the
process
behind you know balancing and adding
mechanics and i think that's really
important
it's cool to see how the sausage is made
sometimes you know for sure yeah yeah
thanks man um you know some of these
things subject to change is still early
in development but that's generally what
i want to go with with the attacks
um and there's little secrets too like
for example um
those guys who float you can one shot
them if you jump and slash because the
jumping slash is slightly stronger
than like the first two hits of the
blade combo so it encourages players to
kind of discover these hidden mechanics
i took a lot of cues from like smash
bros how it's like
every tech has like has like damage data
this does five percent
but the but the um neutral era it does
like eleven percent
so if you jump and hit this blade it'll
take them out in one shot um a little
small guys um
because it does a little more damage um
but yeah it's just like i don't know if
you can tell
i'm really into this game yeah that's
that's tight
so kit tell us um where you can find the
game
where's it gonna be released do you have
any dates i know that it may be tba
um it'll be released on steam and
nintendo switch
um that's what i'm target so pc and
switch right now it's listed on steam
um you can wish listed on steam now um
proto-drake delta you can follow me on
the in games development at
protodroiddelts on twitter
um and then you can check the
kickstarter page uh that's where i
post like monthly updates about
development and a place to keep like a
monthly dev vlog
yeah it's just it's i'm glad i'm glad
he's enjoying it man that's something
that matters the most
yeah i just like really wanted to like
um
emphasize like having a diverse cast and
giving players
who can see folks they can see
themselves in so like one of the other
joys her name is annemarie dorado
and she's latina um and she's like
delta's mentor so all those blade
attacks i
talked about you actually have to find
her hidden throughout different
stages and then she teaches a different
mechanic
while also talking more about her
history because like she's uh they have
a they kind of have
their ethos is kind of at odds like
delta is a prodigy who believes in
bringing
bad guys to justice through like the law
whereas emery dorado is at the
of kind of like the thanos idea like the
lives of the many outweigh the lives of
the few
and so if it means we have to to take
some people out to bring peace
i'm willing to pay their price you know
what i'm saying and so there's a lot of
like like depth in there in their in
their story and
they're in the conflicting kind of views
but they're both heroes you know just
because android is more violent doesn't
mean she's a bad guy
because they're both trying to achieve
peace um it's just there's a conflict in
their in their means and their methods
um
and the cast is majority female you know
what i'm saying it's like i think it's
like the ratio is like um
six to four um a lot of the mean story
leagues
or female leads um so yeah um
yeah i just really wanted to do a lot
yeah thank you so much for joining us
uh everybody can thanks man thanks
kareem we we appreciate it it's the game
wishlist yeah yeah wishlist
on the steam page um we'll talk to you
later for sure
um yeah that was adam kareem with proto
droid delta
i like the game man you were killing it
i love that game
that's i'm all about that right now yeah
it's it's what do you what do you dig
about it
oh i just love the uh the game mechanics
it's like it flows really well
if it's easy to play to get like get the
hang of it
um you know obviously you know i still
need to work on my jumps but
yeah i'll get there i'll be it's solid
the mechanics are solid i'm a big fan of
mega man
and such so yeah go ahead and wish list
that shout out to steam
you know for for working with us on the
wish list page
you can check it out at
mediaindiexchange.com
um show those brothers love you know
wish list them purchase games
but up next we have an interview with
the og
raymond graham no not raymond we had
tony
we got tony tony barnes that's another
og
yeah we got a lot of ogs on here um we
got tony barnes coming up and he's going
to be showing
run die run again all right let's go to
this let's go to the uh the trailer
[Music]
haha
uh the initial trailer for that and we
got tony barnes on the line
what's up man oh hey
how's it going good good it's great to
have you back we had you on the very
first
uh black voices in gaming and you're
back and you've been busting out a bunch
of stuff you've been working on run die
run again and
a few other uh prototypes how has
everything been going with development
hectic like you said man i got
uh uh basically like two and a half
games on the go
and there's just uh one of me yeah for
sure
and you're doing 100 of this all on your
own
pretty much i mean i've started to
enlist uh the
help of my son one of my sons i have
two sets of twins and one of the older
ones who um
also does music he was like yeah we're
kind of getting ahead but it runs
run again um yeah there's like uh
you know there's like uh kind of
a it's like a race game right so like in
race games you know you have
uh music stations and and all that
and so um my son makes different kind of
music than i do
but he still makes some cool music uh
this b-roll does not have music
you know uh because i thought we were
just gonna yak over
but anyway um so he was gonna be making
some music for me and all this stuff but
he's been uh messing around with unity
which this is
uh for about a year or so now
and uh so he's kind of helping me out as
the game
grows and becomes more refined away from
the prototype that i started with
but yeah for the most part yeah you've
been in the business for over 30 years
one thing that i
like which i thought was dope and
hilarious at the same time is you did 28
days
of tony barnes which was magnificent
every day of february black history
month is tony barnes day
and you you had a game a day and those
were not whack titles
like those were some dope titles can you
kind of shed light on
a little bit on your uh history for
folks who don't know about it
okay yeah so uh tony barnes uh
has been doing it actually this will be
the 36th
year professionally um i've been making
games
wow and uh yes i started in
uh uh well i started in 85
professionally but
before that um i was in sixth grade
which was uh when the hell was that
anyway
yeah and so um
you know they put computers in schools
and uh
apple twos actually and nobody really
knew what to do with them
and uh you know outside of playing
oregon trail and [ __ ] so
uh stuff so um
i said yeah i know how these things work
but i didn't really know
how to work uh but i learned really
quickly because
uh it was faster and easier to animate
things on the screen
than it was what i was doing which was
doing like a straight up
pencil you know like old school 2d
animation and i was doing
i was doing like uh uh you know a lot of
i wanted to grow up to be an animator
and um sort of make movies like ray
harryhausen you know
uh clash of the titans and all that fun
stuff doing stop motion
and along come the computers and it was
like oh well
i can move stuff faster hey people like
playing stuff so i'll make my pacman
i'll make my space invaders
and people really liked it and
i was poor i was like dirt poor so
uh i would make these games and then i
would sell them to kids at school
so i got lunch money wow and so
that's kind of how it started in 6th
grade when i was 12.
and then professionally uh when i was
like
15 um i had
done some stuff on a friend's atari
and uh it was more like a friend of me
really you know like uh
like yeah yeah he was one of those guys
that uh
had everything didn't appreciate it and
all that
and was happy to have me over so he
could show off everything that he had
but you know i would i would write on
binder paper in my games
you know and i would write down um all
the sprites and everything and
and then i would walk over to homeboy's
house
and i would take his crap telling me you
know how much better
than me he was and all that fun stuff
now i wasn't going to be anything
uh from making these little games but
then ha ha
here i am 36 years later and the last
time i saw him boy
he was a petroleum expediter i mean i
got nothing against people that you know
work
gas stations and all that fun stuff but
you know if you're going to puff up your
chest and tell me i'm not going to be
anything
um the next time i see you you shouldn't
be you know filling my gas tank
just damn he's throwing shade on the
stream that is a
that is that's so amazing uh you said
petroleum expediter
i've never heard i have never heard that
that was like that's awesome that was
very
similar so how did you so you like fast
forward to
triple a you did so much stuff in in
aaa and working with like uh big
companies and stuff
can you talk a little bit about that and
how you transition
into indie games yeah it's crazy
um uh i always looked a little older
um oddly enough people tell me i look
younger than i
i do now but like when i was younger i
look older
so i can get into bars and there was a
bar you got that
real quick you got that lando look you
mean
oh yeah thanks that's good i like that
you know back in my day seriously though
there weren't there weren't many
there weren't many um uh role models for
uh for my gen you know uh
people nowadays 90s babies you know grew
up with a whole bunch of people on the
screen and all that stuff and we're just
now getting into games and getting more
black faces on on screen but really when
i was growing up there was
um billy d you know sexy lando
and um uh there was a
dad from good times and uh jeff that was
that was it so you know you're saying
that i got the orlando thing
i'm cool james so uh
so yeah i i was in this bar and uh so
were these other guys that were around
my age so none of us were supposed to be
in that bar
come to find out um we were all like
prince fans and homeboy had
a company that he was starting up called
visual concepts and was like oh you
should come with us and all this and do
this and
i didn't really go with visual concepts
but
we kept in touch and um
i told you i had two that's a twin so
one of the the sets twins came
um in 1990 and uh you know you can't
just be out there
um kind of living from paycheck to
paycheck uh doing
spec work and all that fun stuff so i
need to find a real job
and uh he introduced me to people at
electronic arts who were looking for
somebody that
could program maybe do a little art and
definitely design
and i said well i can do all that and so
i joined uh ea
and worked on a handful of things there
like uh madden
and this little thing called the strike
series that people may have heard of
and general chaos and
i don't know any like anything action
wise that was going on
um in the early 90s uh probably touched
you know tested or worked on
and uh that was like my serious
introduction into
aaa before that i worked you know with
companies doing spec work
or did some edutainment but you know ea
was my
my aaa school uh
and what ea is um really good at
teaching you
at least certainly back then was
um how to uh scope
and hit dates because back then it was
like
um here's a line in the sand and uh
here's your box make your game that fits
in that box
right versus a lot of stuff nowadays is
i've got an idea and then you just kind
of plow forward
um fleshing out the idea
and and the problem with that especially
for
aaa is that things are costing you know
like two three hundred million
so yeah you can't really you can't
really uh work that way
but teaches you some discipline and so
uh yeah electronic arts uh
crystal dynamics you know worked on
legacy at kane and uh
worked on a bunch of their stuff while
they were transitioning from the 3do and
the saturn
to playstation so did you know like
testing and stuff on gekks
and and then let's see
um i don't know it's been so much
medal of honor buffy the vampire slayer
star wars episode three um
uh strider strider 2014 yeah
uh super dope that was one of my faves
um yeah you've talked about the 28 days
28 games i
i woke up to black history month and
said
hmm you know uh and i just said it to my
wife i said you know
i should just do a game a day um i
should pick out of the
the 60-some odd titles i've done i
should just
pick a game a day and just for fun
well she's you know she's my biggest
cheerleader
and she's like you know um why are you
going to stop at 28
you know she she gets mad when i when i
download i should do two months you
should have it bleed into march
i think that would be actually pretty
amazing you see you should just drop a
30 more days son
you know what i mean we'll see but you
know i'm a little a little busy
like i said uh two and a half games and
uh just the me
for the most part um and yeah like uh
rundy run again
is um in transition which is why
i uh i couldn't get you guys a uh a
playable because i broke the game
um but i broke it for good for a good
reason it's it's going through a
transition and going to be
uh yeah we're going to play yesterday we
showed it
on game changers with twitch and um
cuppanoodle was like
you really wanted to play the action you
know um
action-paced runs and stuff so
we can't wait on it see it it's um
um what would you do it's a fun game
yeah sorry go on
no go i was i was just saying what would
you say is the like biggest
misconception of people trying to
get in this industry or like making
games and building games like people
think like
oh i got an idea for a game that's your
number one
uh so there's uh
two things we'll we'll start with the
number one real quick
which is um that i have an idea
right and i say this a million times and
i'll say it again
ideas are free but execution costs so
everyone has an idea
but it's important that you can actually
execute on that idea that you can decide
this fits the idea this doesn't fit the
idea and what it takes to actually
make that idea into something you know
that you can actually
see and play and touch and hand to
people
so it's not just about the idea a lot of
a lot of my contemporaries get mad that
i i they think i'm
downplaying the idea ideas are great but
like i said
everybody's got one and i come with
ideas
i don't know i i can be walking down the
street and look at a crack in the cement
and i can come up with an idea
but that you know you have to make it
right
i want to play that and that's the other
the other but like the other the other
misconception is that making games
um is easy
people think that it's either easy or
they certainly think it's easier than it
actually is
it's super hard to even make space
invaders
and that's why i tell i tell anybody
that comes to me and goes uh i want to
make games or you know my kid wants to
make games
what what advice do you have for them
and i say finish something make
something
and make something small take your
smallest idea
and cut that in half and then realize
that you're only going to get half of
that done
because like i said making games is hard
right if you're making it by yourself
it's exponentially harder
getting people together helps but then
there's a management of people
and kind of driving everybody towards a
singular goal
so there's so many moving parts um
it's best to minimize the amount of
moving parts that you have
yeah uh so that you can get in there
and get her done uh somebody else on the
stream i
uh said um you know
don't uh try making your your favorite
idea
first or whatever um and uh and i'm
totally paraphrasing
i'm sorry yeah i was gonna say just real
quick like adam on the last
stream he did the sonic prototype then
he did the mega man prototype and then
he went into proto droid uh
delta and that's exactly what you're
you're saying he's like let me just
build
some stuff and then i'm going to go from
there i want to kind of loop it back
into run die run again so you're talking
about building that
that prototype how did that get you into
um moving towards building run die run
again
and then like actually starting on like
uh full production
yeah so you know i mean um i was in
triple a
i was working on some stuff um i was
working at amazon and
um eventually the game that one of the
games i was leading up
new world will eventually come out and i
hope the best for
my team and all that fun stuff but you
know i have all these ideas and they
come at me really fast and
i just want to make them right but
especially when you're working for a big
company like amazon they don't really
like you
spending your time making somebody
else's game or making you know your own
game it's like no you work for us so
make our game
so i just put this stuff on the shelf um
and then
um last year i was like you know what i
gotta do this
uh i i and my wife's like it's time and
my family's like
it's time you just gotta you gotta go
out and
and do your thing so i'm sitting there
going okay i have all these grand ideas
right even i
even i with all my advice i i have these
grand ideas and i have my magnum opuses
that i want to make
and now i have other things that are
really just about kind of experimenting
with ideas and um
i love running around in destiny i love
the way everything
looks when i'm running around destiny i
love all these movement options i love
shooting through the gun too but
i didn't want to do all that i was like
what can i do that
allows me to run around like that and
then i also love platformers and you
know
games like super meat boy and stuff that
are
a little hardcore um i don't like the
super hardcore
but i like um i like tough ones
this footage is not making it look tough
by the way i should have probably died
more often
um but uh you know so
get all these things together and i
think to myself what can i do
right um regardless of my years in the
biz and all that fun stuff and what i
can do
uh you know artistically and musically
and all that
it uh there's still a lot of things i
can't do
and uh so animating is not my forte even
though i wanted to be an animator so
animating people not my forte
i was like all right first person i
don't have to animate people
um platforming you know what uh people
are getting to the point where they can
actually platform in 3d
so i want to make this this thing used
to actually call a super meat boy first
person for the longest time
and i just kind of started it that way
now that that goes counter to here's the
box and fill in it i learned from ea
uh but that's part of my being indy now
uh me being indie i can just go you know
what i got an idea
and and just you know you know as long
as i can uh pay the bills i can embark
on said idea
and explore it so
i wanted to um explore moving around the
space
you know dodging things it being a bit
hardcore
um and and kind of working on
chaining together moves and building up
momentum
so what you're seeing is actually sort
of uh
my prototype of that now it's probably
prettier than most people's prototypes
um but that's also because i really like
to
do environment art and stuff so um
whenever
yeah i was just gonna say how did you
add diversity
to the game culturally
so uh one of the things
which actually in this footage you've
got the
cyber hands but um
you know all of the characters there's a
there's a set of characters that you can
choose from
and each have their you know they're
each diverse i think there's a hint of
it in the um
at the end of the trailer you see a
woman and she's she's vaulting over
something and she's black woman and all
this and like
she's when i look at the characters and
what i wanted to have in there i was
like okay i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna purposely have a whole
list of
boxes to check like oh gotta make sure
we have this covered that cover
um it was the opposite it was oh good i
don't
have to do anything the only thing that
i know i'm gonna do
is i know i'm gonna put on
a diverse cast characters because if i
don't who doesn't who is
you know i mean like i've worked on
stuff where it's like no you
you know you got to put this person in
there or you know working on somebody
else's
um ip uh you know i i
couldn't make the mace windu game i had
to make the anakin and obi-wan go edit
game yeah
so in this game there's characters and
each character actually has their own
set of movement
so like you know some of them have
double jump or triple jump some of them
have kind of like a princess
peach jump where you jump and glide and
uh you know some of them have like time
stop and all that
and they're kind of all it's all kind of
tied into the
to the character's character you know i
want
like characters that aren't um
typical like you know the the
the the woman that's a kind of
spokesperson
that's on the the end of the trailer her
name's nessa
um she looks like uh
like a real black woman you know she's
kind of thick because
i don't think there's enough of that i
really don't and yet
yeah and she's not um none of my
characters are running around
in uh with their mid-drift showing and
and all that and it's not
i i'm not knocking any game that does
that i'm not saying that i i won't have
a game where
you know some woman's running around the
bikini or guys running around with no
shirt on i might you know who knows
but to me if it doesn't fit it doesn't
fit
yeah this is supposed to be this morning
supposed to be an intergalactic uh
contest right uh
set in like you know some crazy far-off
sci-fi world
um why the hell would somebody be
running around with their you know if
their shirt all down here and all this
with
right but you can make characters that
are appealing and realistic looking
so yeah well thank you thank you so much
tony for
for hopping on board where can we find
the game and look forward to
having it uh
so rdra is uh there's a steam page
um which i think you guys are linking to
in
in all of this you can check it out
media indie exchange
uh it's on steam we have a whole page
that
you can wish list you know or buy some
of the other yeah there you go
yeah and um and you can check out
um all kinds of information on
retroninninja.com
about me and the games going forward
i uh run dice
uh going to be towards the end of this
year
and i have another game um that we
really don't have time to cover and all
that fun stuff
uh but it you know it's a little more
we're gonna have you on
multiple times so you don't have to
worry about you know what i mean
yeah but yeah thank you so much tony for
for jumping on board the triple o g
retro ninja run die run again that's
right
what i want i want that uh early demo
though brother come on
oh yeah no no i'll i'll hook you up i
just
it's just timing i i started ripping
into stuff and i was and then it was
like
you know and i understand you guys you
don't want to you don't want to get a
build the day before
and then have to figure it out yeah yeah
um
we're going to play my bad yeah but
we're ready
but thanks thanks for having me and you
know always
all right and and it's crazy
yeah no problem all right man and the
games the game stuff
all the stuff you guys are showing is
awesome thank you so much yeah i think
so too yeah thanks for your support
no all right all right
and that was tony barnes with run die
run again go ahead and wish list that
next up is game heads we're gonna have
raymond graham on
but before that we're gonna take a quick
break
be back soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we are back from our break we want
to shout out our sponsors before
we uh go and get into the game heads
raymond graham
interview um we have amazing sponsors
without them this would not even be
possible we want to shout out raw fury
playstation
uh humble games razor and kickstarter
and of course we want to shout out uh
humble games as well
for the black game developer fund i am
one of the advisors it's been an amazing
experience working on that
if you want to find out more go to the
link below but
right now we're gonna go into the
trailer for uh
game heads let's hit it
yo what's up humble bundle community my
name is zora mitado and i am the
broadcasting technician for game head
i want to thank all of you for giving
game hands this opportunity
we are honored to be a future charity
this month and i'm here to tell you
about the gametes program
and what we do at gameheads we change
the lives of students of color
and students with low incomes by
training them in video game and tech
industries
we spend the school year learning about
the fundamentals of video game design
development devops and mixed media
then in the summer students form teams
and choose their own roles like level
designer
animator or coder and build a video game
demo over 15 weeks
with the help of our amazing industry
professional mentors
at gameheads we are developing the next
generation industry talent
with your help we can continue to create
opportunities for our students
supply them with valuable hardware and
software provide professional and
academic mentorship
and truly make an impact on the future
of technology
and video game industries so thank you
and stay safe
[Music]
before we hop into the interview uh can
you tell us
you know alfonso because you're a big
part of the program and shout out to
damon too
like how the uh program came to be in
in a little bit about game heads yeah um
damon started the program along with
several of the students so they helped
him co-found
the program and uh because he was
working another organization
and wanted to do game development and
the students were really wanted to get
games
to do games and he just basically
bootstrapped it
and and did it and said if you guys do
your work on the other program
i'll start this thing and he did it and
it took off
and uh um one of my uh
nephews was actually in the in the
program that damon was teaching that i
was super impressed with
uh how he delivered uh and taught the
students
and when he started the game headstand
he's i was like hey you should probably
think about doing some tech stuff too
and he was like let's do it yeah
we could turn the music yeah we got uh
yeah it's
it it is like it's really awesome to
to check that out and there's a ton of
different like studios involved double
five productions
and and ea and unity and yeah right
all of them uh niantic
we have a number of uh studios that are
really donating to the program and
helping we've gotten volunteers and
mentors from
all over the industry which is amazing
it's it's a really
uh cool platform for
uh for kids and and students alike um
let's get right into the interview we
have
raymond standing by what is up raymond
yeah it's going good what's going on
what's up alfonso how you guys doing
good can i get one real quick question
before alfonso jumps in
um what is your background because i
know you have a rich background
right yeah so my background is i've been
in the
game industry for about 22 years now uh
started as a
graphics graphics engineer worked on a
bunch of different games like nba 2k
nba street godfather game bioshock 2
and uh splitter cells especially
blacklist right so spend a lot of time
that's great uh making making a lot of
games and and now i'm at unity um
working with external partners who
use our engine and helping them make
their games uh better and how to use our
technology better
um and i'm also now i'm on
the the board at gameheads and as an
advisor and i do
a lot of the unity instruction uh for a
lot of the students
that's really inspiring yeah yeah i mean
yeah
raymond's uh continually you know
a great mentor to the students he's he's
a um
industry professional he's dedicated to
this program has done
tremendous work for the students and
like i i can't uh
say enough about how hard he works and
how much he gives back to the program
um let's jump into it a little bit um
what so what is like the most rewarding
part of you or why are you part of this
program
right so for the longest time you know
i was heads down working right just
doing my work
and then i you know i looked around and
realized it was like i'm still the only
black face here i'm still one of the
only
black people at the company i'm still
one of the few black folks i know in the
industry right so it's like
like how can i change that how can i
give back how can i share my knowledge
um and then i was talking with um marcus
and lizette and i was like hey how can i
like i hear you guys are involved with
something how can i help
and so i became a mentor at gay men's as
a way of like giving back and helping
grow the next generation of of talent
right in in the industry and and get
kids interested in video games
um like how i got interested i got my
first computer
and i just started working on it that's
how i got in got an industry
and so i just want to make sure that
there's opportunity uh for kids that are
out there
to at least see is the game industry
something that they want to do or not
and uh and then i you know i had the
opportunity to do the mentorship of gay
meds and that really is
what got me involved
and got me got me going with this
and what do you think is some of the
like greatest challenges you encountered
like throughout your career
like to being like the you know soul
black face in some of these
organizations it's it's really hard i
i find that when i'm in the tech
industry um that's it yeah
it's just you know they're alone feeling
alone in us in those roles yeah
but i don't know if i really even
thought of it as like a disadvantage as
i was just kind of like let's just let's
just do it like heads down just keep
going
just even to start like when i went to
school for computer science i was
one of three black folks in the class
right so it's always been like this
right so it's just a matter of i'm not
gonna let that stop me from my
from my goals but i damn sure i want to
make sure that
the next generation have it easier and
have it better
you know what i mean i was just going to
jump in um
what's the most rewarding thing for you
know jumping into game heads
you know and teaching the students
yeah for me it's hard
to teach kids how to make video games
it's hard to make video games yeah yeah
and it's also awesome
it's so hard it's also hard to have the
patience that have the patience uh
to teach a group of young young people
how to make video
games right but when i see the end
result when i see the games that they
they've made over the years
and how impactful some of them are how
well polished some of them are
how fun to play some of those games are
like that is what makes it
worth everything um seeing their
reaction seeing the public's reaction to
the games
seeing people's totally impressed like
that that makes me super happy because
when i was that age i didn't have
any of that or any of those kind of
opportunities
yeah i felt this the same way as you
know i'm a game
indie game developer and not having
those opportunities just having to
to dive in and just testing things out
and learning how to code and all that
but like no
real mentorship that could have fast
tracked me and showed me
i mean we're all going to bump our heads
right but if you can bump your heads a
few less times
that would be very very impactful you
know
right right and if there's also also if
there's mentors there
to help you yeah and tell you tell you
the facts tell you what
what really to expect uh that that also
helps a lot
right yeah and you said your role in
unity is you
you guys are you're specifically your
role right now is helping
companies use the union engine to
improve their games
right yeah so it's about improving their
games but it's also about helping
and improving our engine as well through
what we learned by working with these
partners
and so uh and so that really helps
really helps make sure that the next set
of games are gonna be made on unity
are in a better position because we've
learned some things and we've
done some improvements along the way so
what do you think separates
a good game from like a great game
oh man that's a good question i
really i think the the main difference
the things that i really
care about i think a game has to be very
deep in terms of
it allows everybody in
it's very accessible but then if when
you want to go deeper and
you want to become more skilled there's
another layer to it
and then you grow you grow with the game
and you get more experience at it like
games like fortnite and apex legends
have
like those qualities right where it's
very easy to get into you can have fun
playing it
but then you could really get real
hardcore about it and
go to another level right and to me
that's
most most of the best games have those
qualities right for sure
and how do you ease the students you
know game heads into that because
obviously they're not going to off the
you know off the top hit a
hit uh uh you know what i mean home
run type scenario right like they have
to kind of get eased into it how do you
do that with the students
well for me i don't like my goal at game
as and
for the games that students make isn't
to make good games
that is that is not the goal right the
goal is for them to learn the process
of making video games and it's for them
to unders
and part of that too on the engineering
side
is for them to become better engineers
learn
coding learn about some of the more the
more in-depth
topics that's really the goal um so that
and if they make a good video game in
that process
more the better right but we're
preparing them
for whether they really want to go into
the industry or go to post-secondary
education
that they will be in a better position
once they're there
right and then they can think about how
to make a good game
once they know what they're doing right
one of the things i love about raymond
and i i you know
i say this all the time when we're in
person uh
when we get back to being in person is
that uh
raymond is not easy on the students like
there's no
like there's no cuddling there's like
you gotta you gotta do the work
he's like you gotta show up you gotta
like really like invest in yourself and
i think that's
the the thing you have to do with our
folks is like look
you're not gonna get no one's gonna like
hand hold you through
a a role if you get one of these jobs
triple a companies like
you know raymond's gonna be there like
oh it's okay buddy you can you can just
not do
good like yeah i think that's extremely
important because there's you know
sometimes in these other programs
there's a lot of hand-holding
and you can't do that it's like oh yeah
i'm black so i can
you know they're gonna hand me this
stuff you know affirmative action it's
like no we gotta work twice as hard as
anyone else
um and we need mentors to help us and we
can't they can't necessarily always be
easy on us
you know what i mean that's right yeah
yeah
yeah they ask me all the time they're
like ray how did you get so good at
programming or how did you
get to where you are and the answer is
really easy it's like
yo you got to practice and try hard but
you know
you just have to keep practicing the
craft and keep going
and you get better over time with more
practice right like you see me do this
real fast now
but i've been doing this for like 30
years like of course i'm really doing
this really fast right you have to build
up
that skill and that knowledge you know
what i mean right
that's totally true super impressive um
and what do you think are there specific
barriers for folks of color in this
industry
um that especially in this industry
honest honestly i think one of the when
i was coming up
i think a lot of the barriers a lot of
the
like technical and practical barriers
are really not there these days when i
was coming up when you wanted to make a
video game
you had to build the entire video game
yourself
right you had to write the renderer you
had the right
the control systems physics you had to
do all that yourself that's a lot of
things to know
and a lot of knowledge you have to find
somewhere uh these days with engines
like unreal and unity
and and godot like there's a ton of
injuries out there that
really lower the barrier to entry
um but for but for black folks there's
still like you know there's still
like wealth wealth gap disparities
and so that that limits that might limit
opportunity to get access to a computer
that can run
these these uh engines and things like
that uh
and then just the knowledge like the
video game industry is also very
insular very small yeah and so then how
do you
how do you get that information and the
knowledge out
so that folks even know if it's
awareness and how
uh to make uh video games right i think
those are the the barriers that we're
facing like today
yeah and that's what some of the things
that the game has program is solving
like one of my roles with
the program is to make sure the students
have computers that can actually run the
unity engine
and you know they have access to you
know that stuff so
um and then access to mentors like like
raymond
um it is ultimately very important to
have those
those tools yeah yeah i mean we we super
appreciate you jumping on and everything
you do
for game heads game heads is such an
amazing uh you know program and i think
we need this to be
i know it's worldwide we talked to
lizette yesterday actually she was
she was talking about game heads and
psychonauts too
and we talked to marcus last time every
time we should have
these discussions is extremely important
you know
yeah yeah and it's been it's been like
it's been hard and it's been fun like to
do this and work with
alfonso and damon and marcus lizette and
paul
and everybody it's been it's been a fun
fun ride and like and we're seeing
great success and a lot of progress and
nothing makes me happier than doing this
for sure
well thank you so much raymond for
joining us that's uh raymond graham
where can we find you actually oh man
i'm on
the best place to follow me is on is on
twitter and it's it's
water us on twitter w-a-d-a-r-a-s-s
[Laughter]
and if you're jamaican you know what
that means but yeah
that's that's he's also on linkedin okay
we'll check
check you online
and professionally i'm on linkedin
that's ray ray graham yeah
okay cool cool well yeah shout out to
gameheads if you want to find out more
about game heads how can we do that
you can definitely go to gameheads
oakland.org and donate
um you can check out the the board and
all and being mentored to the program if
you're a ninja in the industry as well
you know
cool yeah you could just also just if
you're interested in being a mentor
just drop me a dm and i could direct you
to right people
cool thank you so much raymond thanks
brother appreciate it man
take care y'all all right all right
up next we have a amma from uh
michelle nakunja from join play games
we're gonna launch the trailer right now
and get right into it
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
that was the trailer for alma from uh
join play games um the game is
is gorgeous it's beautiful um the thing
i really love about this game is that
it it's basically depicting culture that
you don't get to see in games
and um and it's actually beautifully
designed
i would love to you know i want to
definitely get my hands on this game
so it's going to be it's on my my wish
list yeah it's definitely like
you know um top five for me uh
of the upcoming games that we have on
here um we
have uh michelle nakunja i actually
spoke with him before
because he is part of the black game
developer fun for humble games and
he's an african developer so we're
seeing this like slew of awesome games
from black from black developers from
africa
come out of the woodworks and they're
making these this amazing content and
these games that look like really triple
a and they have big teams and stuff
um so it's awesome to see that we we
hope to talk with him soon
uh uh michelle nakunja and
they are part of the also a part of the
humble black game developer fund
we want to shout out to our sponsors
again um
if you're interested in taking part of
the black game developer fund you can
check out the link below and then we
want to shout out our sponsors
once again because they are helping to
make this stream
possible shout out to twitch shout out
to valve and steam to
raw fury of course playstation humble
games razer
and kickstarter um and we're gonna roll
to our next developer uh with
are we at she dreams elsewhere
um and let's roll the trailer
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you have a dream of something
[Music]
[Music]
do you ever dream of something
[Music]
is
[Music]
that's what i dreamed
[Music]
[Music]
that is she dreams elsewhere we have
davion
on the line the game the game looks
really amazing we were playing it
earlier uh and we played the trailer
yesterday and people were really digging
it
yeah i love the visuals in the game it's
it's it's
aesthetically it's just breathtaking yo
what's up davion
hey man how's life it's good
i love your setup it's gorgeous ah
thanks man i've always said that like if
i wasn't like a game developer i'd be
like
an interior designer or something so uh
i appreciate the compliment
for sure everything's been blowing up
for you man like you've been featured
all these different places and
i'm not so how has development been
going for the game
uh well you know it's coming i mean
2020 kind of put like a wrench in like
literally everything
um but now it's like i'm like really
excited like how it's been going
um a lot of like exciting such like show
some new announcements coming up
like uh later this year so um yeah i'm
just
i'm ready to be done with this game and
i'm ready for y'all to finally
experience it
nice nice so we're going to get into it
we're uh
actually playing the right game right
now alfonzo's playing it can you tell us
a bit
we had you on the stream before but
please tell us a little bit about your
background and what led you here to
developing games
independently yeah for sure um see i'm
based out of cleveland ohio
uh born and raised um i started making
games
about like 11 years ago when i was in
fifth grade um
just kind of like messing around
generally know what i'm doing i still
don't know what i'm doing
um but in high school i was like hey
like i kind of want to like
see if i can make like some type of like
career out of this
um so i went to like a few like
prototypes uh all of them kind of sucked
in some way or
some form or fashion uh but eventually
in my senior year i landed on shifts
elsewhere
um and at first it like it went through
that cycle of
like um oh hey i'm like working on this
one project
but there's this other idea that i got
let me go like play with this idea sort
of fit for a little bit see what's good
with over there
um and usually that resulted in like the
previous project like just getting like
canned
um and it all and it almost happened to
this one
but um there was something about i was
like i have to just like keep making
this game i have to like just see it
through
um so yeah that was like five years ago
though i was gonna take about three
months uh so yeah here we are
still in this nightmare it fits
so well i mean that that's kind of
another reoccurring
you know theme is like we're just
spending so much time like sean was like
nearly 10 games on treachery and
beatdown city
so and i've been there too um can you
talk a little bit about
the background of the game and the
narrative in general
yeah so basically the whole concept is
that you're playing nostalgia and a coma
you gotta find out like i got in a coma
find a way to wake up confront your
inner nightmares and just have like this
horrible trippy
personal experience the entire time um
and
for me like i've always been like super
like into this like dreams and like how
they can affect
how they can like reflect like your own
like um like what you're going through
emotionally
um and plus like it just allows like so
much just like
um like creative freedom like you can
pretty much like do
whatever you want in a dream uh for
better or worse development wise
um see i just always been like super
into dreams
very into like the surreal and the weird
stuff um
and it's like ultimately just like kind
of making like whatever like weird stuff
that i want to which thankfully i've
been able to do so far so
appreciate that
so what are you what are you doing right
now what is uh alfonso doing
in the world yeah so right now you're
going through
the first like official level uh this is
oblivion uh beforehand
you had like this like really weird like
bad dream
you woke up your friend dragged you to a
party that you didn't want to go to
um and at that point you were like ah
not really feeling this had an anxiety
attack
fun times uh so you're like all right
i'm out
going back home i'm done with this uh
but as you left
you kind of like found yourself in like
this weird like dream like hell escape
um so now at this time like dodge is
kind of like
trying to like find her way out figure
out like what is going on find her dog
because like her dog's here for some
reason
um and uh we'll see where it goes from
there
can you describe the combat because i
think it's it's really interesting it
has that kind of fantasy star
aesthetic you know um old school
yeah i'm like a huge fan of just like
old scorpios like final fantasy dragon
quest
persona earthbound especially if it
wasn't obvious enough
yeah earthbound i forgot about that one
for sure
yeah one of my favorite games of all
time uh that and weather3
but um yeah so basically combat it's all
about just kind of like
getting through battles as like as
efficiently as possible um
so basically if you like striking
enemies like weak point you can sign up
for a turn
but if you stun all enemies then you get
to like uh just link up with like your
whole party
do you like this devastating attack um
it's kind of like end things like that
much quicker
um so it's all about just like
exploiting weaknesses getting through
battles as quickly as possible because
i've
i've kind of learned especially like as
i've like uh gotten older and
while playing rpgs is that like i love
the battle systems i love the mechanics
um but eventually it's like all right i
kind of want to like
get like get on with it you know um
so i kind of described this game as like
an rpg for adults who have
things to do right so yeah battles are
like a supers quick
um i try to keep it as simple as
possible while still like having death
with the two
um and like overall like lane of the
game was like just five to ten hours
like
like theoretically if you wanted to
unless you could just like marathon this
entire game in like a weekend
if not like a day even so that's perfect
how did you use contemporary mechanics
for a game that has
kind of that old-school appeal
um it just kind of like comes like my
own like personal preferences like
um like i said like i love like the
whole like old school style but like i
i didn't want to bring like more like
quality of life updates to it like
there's no like random encounters
um your hp and your uh sp like they
restore like after every single battle
um and then the final game is gonna be
like difficulty options more
accessibility options
um just basically any way that like
more people can like get through this
game um
i'm cool with that that's like my goal
and you're doing
like are you you're developing every
aspect of this game
or are you like what is your team like
team dynamic
yeah so it's mostly just me um beyond me
i have my composer mimi page who's
absolutely amazing she composed like all
the original scores
um there's my character designer yanina
he makes like the actual like full
like full scale illustrations and like
the character portraits um and then i
also have my
reporting team who's like getting the
game on the consoles and uh papaji into
my pr team who like does like uh the
bigger like uh press beats but beyond
that
at this point at the moment it's just me
going insane in this dungeon that i call
an apartment
where are you at where are you located
uh cleveland cleveland heights oh okay
that's which i do not recommend at all
i cannot wait to get out what
what are some of the challenges that
you've had with development that you
said the game has been in development
for five years right
yeah it's just i think the biggest thing
for me especially like during this past
year
is just like keeping focus and like that
like motivation up
um especially like in this past like 12
months where it's like every day it's
just the same like i barely leave the
house like i'm just
like i'm always surrounded by my game
like uh i was talking to my friend like
a few months ago and he was like yeah
like
you decorate your apartment just like
your game and i was like oh my god
you're right like i'm too lost in the
sauce like i'm trapped here
um so yeah it's just like kind of
keeping up that motivation just like
powering through and like prioritizing
well um
i'm still struggling with that but like
it ultimately used to take it one day at
a time
what are some of the final touch touches
because the game is uh
it's coming close to release right
yeah it's just right now it's just like
a lot of looks like uh finishing up
content
uh lots of polishing i've yet to go to
the balancing phase which for an rpg
oh god i like i'm not good at math
which is like really ironic considering
that i'm making an rpg
um but yeah it's just those like little
like final details
um they just take up a lot of my time uh
plus like uh external stuff like just
um i can't really like marketing like
you know talk like other devs and like
networking like all that stuff um
see there's a lot but uh it's a fun time
yeah for sure i was like i was always
thinking about what it would take to
make
you know a real-time strategy game or a
turn-based like tactics game and then i
thought about that math
problem and i'm like damn that requires
some you know additional skills for sure
so i feel that but i never thought about
that you know
balancing for your game in general
yeah thank god for like rpg maker which
like um that's like the main
engine that i use for the uh pc and mac
versions oh
that's cool and yeah it yeah it like
they're still believe me there's still a
lot of them that have to be done but it
um
it simplifies things enough to where i
can just like focus on just like
on like the game itself and the creative
aspect and just like just hitting the
ground running with that
did you also compose the music too
because that's one of the things that
like really stands out like the kind of
lo-fi
chill moody music you know it has this
vibe to it
it makes me want to talk like barry
white you know what i mean
yeah um yeah that part that was them i'm
a composer maybe paige
okay she it's it's it's funny how he met
because like she met me
off of my imdb imdb page which is very
outdated
do not go look at it we don't talk about
those movies or trash
but um steven's else was on that page
too
i mean she found me like way back in
like 2016
she was like hey like i love your game i
love your concept like
i want to make music for you like i
don't care like what i need to do like i
would do anything to like make this
happen um and we just
have like just such like a dope
relationship like since then um i love
her i love her music
and yeah just shout out to mimi
yeah yeah shout out to her it definitely
pulls through and
you like i really like the limited color
palette it really stands out
like you said i could and i didn't even
get put two and two together but like
when i looked at your background
with the blue and the the purple
flourishes
it that does definitely you know come in
lost in the sauce man
no i totally get it you know what i mean
um
so how did that how did you come up with
that you know the
the art style for the game total
accident
like the full like the original cops of
the game was like in
like this full like uh like colorful
like more like earthbound like type of
style
um and i pressed the wrong button one
day like early on and it made like every
like the enemy graphic i was working on
like entirely black and white
um and i was like that's kind of wrong
but like it looks cool um
so i started like having like just the
enemies being black and white
and then i was like okay what if i make
everything black and white
and then what if i make everything black
and white but like add like a little
a little spice of color here and there
um and yeah i just feel like developing
it from there like i just love the color
i like i love colors in general like
if it wasn't obvious enough yeah for
sure
and what you have to do a lot like you
have to do business development you have
to
you i know you were working with some pr
for folks but you also do marketing and
stuff what do you think is
one of the the most challenging aspects
of like putting the full package
together
because it's all these elements composed
into one
you know game it's just more like
just really just like keeping track of
like everything and like where
everything is
um especially like when you're working
alone like you know like
they're like games take whole teams to
develop
but when it's just like you doing it's
like right look i gotta like work on
like the animation but i also need to
like finish writing but i also need to
like
do the level design but also it's like
email this one guy like wants to
interview
and also like like you know do like all
this other stuff and like it's just
it's a lot um so i'm still working on
that aspect
it's really hard uh do not make a game
of this scope alone i do not recommend
it
um but it's coming it's coming on one of
these days
do you have like so you're finishing
this up you you must have
uh different projects that you want to
work on in the future in your head or do
you ever like
veer off and and spend a little bit time
tinkering and making little
uh prototypes um
let's like prototype some more just like
just writing uh because i want to
uh in addition like doing like games i
also like i'm like a filmmaker and like
photographer
um so i have like photography side
projects i have like a photo shoot like
tomorrow actually
oh nice um and yeah and i also like
not to like reveal my hand just yet but
i've uh been working on my my next like
feature film script in addition like
just
brainstorming the next uh game but uh
i don't know like i i don't really know
what's happening after this game
the future is bright but it's also very
scary yeah
i understand like you don't even want to
think about that until after this
sometimes till after this stuff is done
because it's such an arduous process
um what what is like that's so
interesting about your film background
how did how did that get started how did
you get started in film and
screenwriting and stuff um
it's really weird like i was like always
like in the film like from
like when i was a kid um to the point
where i would like
make like these storyboards like in like
these notebooks like complete with like
these fake credits and everything
um so i always just like love cinema um
and then
in high school like around my sophomore
year um i was like hey like
this game stuff it's cool but like i saw
i forget like what movie it was
i want to say it was like uh gone girl
um i saw that in theaters and i was like
yo this is dope like i got the drive to
like
make a movie now uh so like the next
week i called up my friends i was like
yo
we're making a short film next few weeks
i have no clue how to do it but we're
gonna do it
um so from then on i've been like just
making like short films i made
um two feature films again both of which
are trash
do not ask about them i will not be
answering any questions i was about to
ask
those feature films i'm i'm gonna go uh
on your imdb
page right after this so i'm about to
get exposed
no but yeah i i really do love films i
have like more plans for films on the
on the horizon um and there is there
definitely
is like crossover between like my game
process and like film process too so
it's
like i am just like a naturally creative
person and if i can just like
make something like no matter what the
medium that it is
i'm a happy boy yeah i was think i was
going to say how does your experience
from filmmaking bleed into
your game obviously there's a narrative
uh design and different elements there
it's just like a lot of just some like
just kind of like capturing that like
i feel like i'm going to pronounce this
wrong again like miss onsen like just
like
you know capturing like the right like
vibe like directing it like
uh to like fit the vision um and also
like from a more like production
standpoint like
filmmaking is like inherently just like
a much more well not like much more but
in my current situation it's much more
collaborative compared to like this game
where it's like
you know it's mostly just me uh but even
so then like just having like those
skills like
um collaborate and like connect with
like other like partners and like the
press and like all that stuff
um stuff like that it really comes in
handy too so
for sure what would you um
recommend aspiring developers do to get
started in the business as a developer
don't video games were hell man i like
why why would you i don't even know why
any of us are doing this
um but if you're gonna continue on with
that fool's decision like i did
and which i'll most like continue to do
um i would just say
just get started just make something uh
start small
especially but just like the biggest
step is just like making
that first step um no matter like what
form it takes
just like put your voice out there get
feedback put it out to the world
um just like keep making stuff
afterwards um
because no matter like no matter like
what i've made or like the quality that
it's been
like i've always like learned something
from each and every single project
that's like uh like grown over time like
she dreams elsewhere
it would not be like what it is today
like i felt like all those like past
games
that i've done for fun without like all
like the shitty like feature films that
i've done
like it's it's like like life is like a
learning process
so i would just say just like start that
learning
uh as soon as you can and you had so
you you had previous game projects um
can you talk a little bit about those
what were some of your other games that
you
you created before she dreams elsewhere
yeah they were just like mostly just
like super like small projects like
um i think i did a count like years ago
which i'm pretty sure it was like
kind of inaccurate now um but at that
time i like
worked on like 60 games of my own uh
most of which were just like i'm going
to play around with this
don't don't get too excited yet i was
like like most of them
that's crazy yeah most of those projects
were just like
i'm gonna like it's me like as like in
like six between like sixth grade to
like
you know sophomore year of high school
and like just tinkering around and like
for like a day or like a week or like a
few weeks just like making whatever
uh most of those games were to finish um
out of those six games i think like 12
of those i actually
like finished and like shipped out to
like the internet um just like putting
on this like random just like rpg maker
sites
uh that got like barely like any
downloads but it was still like a
learning experience
um it was still like a good chance like
just connect with like some sort of like
like like external like game dev
community too so
again like it's all like learning
process yeah yeah how did that like
how did that work when you started in
the community is that community that
you're you've been working with like
still there are you still communicating
with the same people who tried your
games early on because i think that's
like an important part of the process is
kind of building a community
surrounding uh your vision as a you know
a director of these games
yeah i've like always just like loved
like the rpg maker community
been involved since like pretty much
since i got started with rpg maker like
all those years ago um and there's
people from uh like way back then like
we're still like friends to this day
like even like on facebook like
instagram or just like you know
hit each other up like still following
each other um
and yeah they've always been like just
super supportive um i definitely made
like a lot of mistakes
starting like back in the day like
especially like
like when i get like got started like
making games it was also like
my first time like really like
communicating with other people on the
internet
um as like a fifth grader so it's like
there is definitely like some just like
like looking back i was like oh man like
why did i say that why did i do that
like
why um but again
learning process mistakes are made but
we get past them
yeah it's really cool like that you know
the unreal community and the unity
community and like the rpg maker
community like it's such
there's such a large breadth of of
content and
creators you know hobbyists and
professionals and stuff it's so
interesting
um we got to tell alfonso where to go in
this game
i'm making progress man he's smashing it
up
oh you are you actually yeah you put in
that work i see you
yeah you give me enemies okay
[Music]
you gotta hit those weak points
experiment with skills
they're smashing it up for sure
you got that limit bar feel too you
could use your dahlia special skill if
you want to if you want to i mean
you're the one with the sticks you know
some skills you got
roast where do you get the ideas for
these characters these enemies are super
dope looking
um usually just like either my dreams or
just like random like shower thoughts
um and also just like just like i'm
experimenting art like just
in general like literally this entire
apartment like there is like not a
single blank wall around it
um see i just like i love just kind of
experimenting around with stuff
um and then from there it's like okay
what would this enemy do
um like where is saliya at like in the
game right now like what's their like
mental like mindset
uh what like lesson does she need to
learn right now in this level
and like how do i make her learn that
like through either the narrative or the
mechanics
in like the worst possible way so it's a
fun time
yeah yeah so it progressed like her her
mental stability progresses
how is how does the story progress along
with the gameplay
yeah ultimately it's just like a story
about like how it's okay to not be okay
um oh okay and and even though what the
concept and like some of like the
like aesthetic is like kind of like uh
comes off it's like just like very just
like
moody and like dour um ultimately the
whole story is like this
this is like a story of like just
keeping up hope and like optimism
even in like the darkest times which i'm
not sure if anybody can relate to that
right now
yeah yeah cool yeah i was i was kind of
joking about that
uh yesterday with cup of noodle when we
were
looking at the trailer about how it's
like you know it was
like last week it was raining outside
and this is like just the perfect game
that fits that
you know that mood you know what i mean
what kind of games do you like to uh
to play you know i was gonna say to get
you in the mood but that's a little
suspect
[Laughter]
you know that kind of like take you away
from development
uh so i literally play smash ultimate
every single day multiple times a day
that's like how it's kind of like how i
get like my like
anger and frustration out low-key it's
like going online getting my ass beat
most of the time
uh yeah i just smashed a fortnight
again like just being bodied by like
these random kids
yeah it's like if it feels horrible but
like it feels good to just like release
it um
nintendo for that one yeah for sure the
game is the game is super dope well
thank you so much for
sharing uh she dreams elsewhere thank
you thanks davey i'm good and how can we
find you how can we find a game
yeah so me personally i am at
daveyandgooden
um on twitter instagram and ticktalk
uh and for the game itself i'm at
studiosveer
on twitter instagram not on tik-tok yet
but soon i've been dragging my feet on
that
do not sleep on tick tock it's amazing
um but yeah i wish this game on steam
if you want to it's a free country um
and yeah it's coming out
eventually one of these days i promise
definitely looking forward to it and and
uh appreciate you coming on and
and congrats on everything that's been
happening it's it's super awesome to see
you flourishing
and such no i'm trying i'm trying my
best but thanks y'all i really
appreciate that for sure yeah
yeah shout out to steam uh and we'll
we'll definitely talk with you
uh later man we'd love to have you back
on
of course but yeah you can wish listed
now
it's on um the mix steam page
black voices and gaming um next up
we have site but first
let's let's have a little break let's
jump on a little break um
and we will be back in a couple minutes
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we are back with black voices of
gaming thank you so much for joining us
we have site uh on the line now
she is representing um the the humble
black
game developer fund also global game jam
i think i butchered your last name can
you please tell us
i freaking a every time that you know
what i mean
i told you just don't say it i told you
just don't say it i can't help it
you know what i mean yeah it's got a
click which i
which um i'm pretty sure americans like
aren't familiar with it so
a little bit like um that's how you say
it but don't try it at home don't hurt
yourself
okay just let it go bro yeah
for sure and i i think it's awesome i've
been working with you for the past
what is it almost six months right since
october oh
yeah wait um yeah i guess four months i
don't know but since october or
before that we we got to each other
before that yeah
yes yes so it's been a while it's been
amazing um site is also
on the black game developer fund as well
as i am and
and it's been such a journey working
through that process and
one thing that i thought was really
interesting is just your perspective
being african um and working with
developers from the community can you
give us
um a little bit about your your personal
history
in the game development space
oh okay so my personal history in the
game development space so
uh in 2013 um this was like
i forget i was like 19 i think but like
um i was working at a space at a tech
incubator and
um i think tech incubators they're
popular in all sorts of places in africa
like um but it's usually like tekken
business incubator
and i was working there and um
they were encouraging me to like you
know because it was a space for
innovation and stuff so they encouraged
me to like pursue
any of my interests or whatever so my
bosses um
saw that i was interested in game in um
games and they told me that oh there's
this guy who made a game and at that
time like i'm in zambia and i have never
heard of anyone making a game video game
before
like as in so they told me that someone
made uh their old video game
um and he's he's been here before i know
like oh who's that and
funny enough like someone from my high
school told me like oh my my cousin made
made a video game once and i was like oh
really and it turned out it was the same
person
and um when i learned that you can make
your own game
like he made a game based on his own
comic um he's on jrpg
in java and he did everything in java
did all the drawing in java and all that
stuff so it was like a
fight it was a fighting game a jrpg
style fighting game made
based on a comic he had of a
post-apocalyptic africa
and i was just like and he did
everything by himself every single thing
he did by himself in java and i was like
whoa that's
like insane and i was like also
also i was like that means like we like
people can actually do it like that
shows that people can actually do it
um yeah so after i
heard that after i learned that i was
like hmm
i wonder how many other people they are
around so this was 2013 and i was like i
wonder if there are any other people
around
who have made games or if anyone would
be interested in learning how to make
games so
i started exploring tools for game
development i learned about stencil
and construct and that kind of stuff and
then i learned about global game chan
so it was really there when i started um
seeing
um like with starting a game development
community
in zambia from that and um becoming a
part of
a more global game development community
through global game jam i was like wow
like
people are learning how to make games by
themselves using all sorts of tools
so i just stayed there like super
interested since i've been a gamer since
i was really young and
um i was just reminded recently that
there was a time i made a board game
when i was a kid uh
using cardboard and stuff it was like
monopoly but for everyday life and
my friends came over to play but yeah i
forgot about that but you know
yeah but then but then i just thought
yeah
people um you know like i was just
learning about
people in different places in africa
making games so
um so that was 2013 i did a lot of stuff
with that and
then in 2014 i came to study in south
africa and south africa
has its own indie game scene you know
south africa is famous for
bro force from three lives and um yeah
yeah so yeah they
sorry i know i've been rambling the
difference between sort of the
indie game scene there that than it is
here
like what do you think are some of the
sort of differences
that you you can you mean in south
africa yeah
oh gosh a lot i mean first of all
[Laughter]
this event right now black voices in
gaming um
first of all like most of the developers
from south africa
are white men the developers who you'll
know about like if you
um like uh
free um free lives um all other popular
games you hear about
most likely will be made by a white man
in south africa
um so there is not there is really
really
very i don't know if that's a similarity
or a difference but like there is such a
little representation of
um that game it's weird no it's it's
really weird because like
um white people are the minority in
south africa like by far the minority
by far the minority
by far and then yes i need to emphasize
by far the minority in south africa
um so it's very strange it or it's it's
it's um it's very noticeable it's
extremely noticeable
that most of the games in south africa
are made by a small minority
and the actual people who represent the
majority of the country are not shown in
the game scene so that's like a huge
problem already
um and um something and i think so
um like i was saying before it'll end
the
conversation i was having before but
like when i came to south africa to
study and
the thing is i had that hunger for
wanting to know about game development
communities so i was reaching out to all
sorts of south africans and
they invited me to events and like i
could fit in one
in those events i guess because um i
if if you just meet me on if you if a
lot of people can't tell where i'm from
when they hear me talk and whatnot like
um i have a very neutral accent
and all that so and i know most um
i like i have a very kind of western
sensibility in terms of like um
games and stuff like that so people so
people so i i'm i guess i'm approachable
in that sense like i'm approachable in
that sense so it makes it easier for me
to integrate into like um
different types of into these different
types of communities whereas you know
someone who
like might have a different perspective
on what games they can
make or someone who might have a
different perspective on the scene
um yeah i feel that honestly i feel that
when i go to events so
where are you like so where are you from
originally i'm from zambia originally
zambia
yeah um
as far as sort of women of color being
represented in the indie game industry
in in zambia what do you what do you see
there
even worse even worse than what i like
yeah like already like the in terms of
black represent
gosh it's so it's so it's so
so little like so few so few so few um
game um indie game developers or game
developers or even just people working
in the games industry are
african women and um um
it's they're like i'm still trying to
find answers to it like it's it's
something which i've been trying to find
answers for since 2015. um
or yeah because um since 2015 like um
hosting game development events
in zambia i started hosting um an
all-girls game development workshop in
since like 2015 to get more people more
women involved in global game jam
and the thing is that event was like it
was really it was um
pretty successful and um it was really
nice getting to know the women and
interestingly enough the women who i see
who i see almost um
every day i guess or and i didn't even
know that they were like so interested
in games and even had an interest in
game development
so there's like a silent there's a
really a silent a lot of people who have
a silent
um desire to get into game development
but you know
the thing is you get a lot of there's
still a lot of this basic
um this basic perspective these basic
opinions about
oh you're a girl and you play games like
you know there's that kind of stuff
which
um you know guess makes people
uncomfortable to even like
be be like visible women who are gamers
so much like even in terms of um
like i guess it's changed for women in
coding and tech and stuff
but like it's still an uncomfortable
space to be in and that's that's what
i've been getting all these years that's
that's the one thing which i'm very sure
of that it's still an uncomfortable
space
for women in africa to be in like even
not just from their peers but even i
guess you know from family members and
stuff like that
you mean being gamers like being gamers
yeah
being games yes being gamers and also
being game developers like that's even
worse so like being gamers is already
one thing and
then being um interested in actually
pursuing game development is
another thing it's just like um yeah
it's just something else
what makes you different because you're
obviously in the gaming community
and obviously this is something that you
you love to do but you don't seem to
let whatever those those cultural or you
know
uh societal uh reflections of you
i don't know i guess i guess i'm i've
been i guess i'm used to being an
outsider um
for for a while i've been used to being
an outsider when i was in primary school
um i yeah i'm just used to being outside
i guess so it didn't even bother me and
the thing is it's like
one of the only few joys i get in my
life is is from video games so
like you know i'm not gonna suppress
that like what else am i gonna what else
am i gonna do like what else am i gonna
talk about like if
it or what else can i be passionate
about if it's not
video games and stuff like that if if
yeah so i don't feel the need to hide it
i don't want to hide it because i i like
i i like it i like the space that i'm in
um
and um also maybe it's also because like
i grew up like with my brothers and
cousins
uh my i have three brothers and
um i mean from the youngest time
like we we're all really good at tekken
in our family or we were all really good
at taking this veneers we got to play
i know we've talked yeah i'm a tekken
let's jump into uh the the um black game
developer fund i
i uh i really want to talk to you about
that because
and you can jump in too obviously but
you actually are representing a
continent like you know what i mean
you're representing
africa there and you're seeing
everything that's going on
you know i'm helping to represent europe
and uh the us
and what is your uh
experience been with that because
obviously it evolved
from the beginning until now
huh so it's
my experience with that has been
it's you know people are still
like really want to make mobile games in
africa so it's
it's it's so hard finding people who are
making pc games
um through the black game developer fund
uh
so it's it's just chat it's a challenge
it's a challenge but
the thing is i think i you know
my experience is that you know you know
games like
arma so i think arma and
um orion which isn't part of bg df but
it's also a cameroonian game
i think seeing success stories like that
like might motivate people more to
invest in pc games and um creating their
own ip through that so
uh that's that's the challenge i've had
the challenger pad is that most people
want to make mobile games like because
they know they're like you know
they're like it's easy as a business
model you can just say oh most africans
mostly
are on mobile and all that stuff um but
yeah but i do think we need more people
making pc games because it's not just
it's not just about the game it's about
the intellectual property as well like
yeah and exporting it and you think the
focus is because of the economics around
the mobile gaming and
because they're yeah pc gaming yeah
yeah because i mean it's it's easy
yeah it's easier to just prove to like
prove it as a
business model or or it's just easy to
to
sell that to people just say so man so
many africans are on their mobiles like
every african uses a smartphone blah
blah blah we can get so many players
into this
it's that that's that's that's how um
that's how it's easier to sell like that
but like selling uh
console games because people don't even
really track console sales
um in africa i don't think so i don't
think people try console game sales in
africa but it's more it's easier to see
like analytics for like app sales and
all that stuff so
yeah yeah there is definitely no
visibility there so we
like as we're uh we watched this evolve
what were some of the things that you
saw
trending i mean let's just get real
about this so
we we started working with humble we we
saw these
developers come in uh these black game
developers from all over the world and
we were like okay initially was like
okay this was a
a publishing scenario and then it was
like oh well these
developers need a lot of help you know
what i mean outside of that so yeah can
you explain a little bit about how
how it progressed yeah it's
exactly what you're you're saying and um
thing is i was actually
i was actually really surprised because
you know the thing is um this is my
first experience working
um with a publisher but um you know
with my i guess like background
experience um
um you know working at a tech incubator
and all this stuff and
um writing grants and all that stuff and
project and learning project management
so i thought that as a junior i was
going to be um
i i mean i thought like seeing
people stuff for the first time i
thought i was going to be seeing
a lot of people like just um selling
selling themselves really well
but then i learned that you know that
people actually um
a lot of people didn't know how to sell
their games like they didn't know how to
pitch their games and i was actually
very surprised about that
and then i realized and then yeah we
came to realize
realization that you know okay people
need help with um
also being able to pitch their games and
um
you and use and like even when people
pitch their games you could tell
like people are underselling themselves
a lot and then i'm like like
yeah i'm yeah exactly and the thing is
like i'm from africa like i
like we learn to do things like on such
a small budget so
if and i have like basically
no income very little income and i was
like if i can tell you that you're
underselling your game you're
really understanding that like yeah so
yeah so i was surprised about that
yeah i was surprised about that too a
lot of the developers even like the
developers who worked in aaa before were
having like
you know some of those struggles of
underselling it not saying that they
need five hundred thousand dollars
saying they
they were needed two hundred thousand
dollars being way under budget but
having this amazing game
and already having these prototypes so
uh
yeah that's like that's something that
we definitely gotta hit on
um yeah well can you tell us a little
bit about the the black game developer
fund and
and where to find out about it and how
to apply
uh haven't you already said that you've
probably sent this a lot
i said it like a thousand times but i
want to hear from your perspective
oh my gosh like um uh
i just google uh humble games black game
developer fund or something and it shows
up but
i think it's go to humblegames.com
blackgame.fund um but whatever the url
is going to be shared here i just know
it's like
like when i type it it shows up on my
autocomplete so
i don't know what the url exactly is but
yeah but
um people were there were still open for
submissions um
there's a new submission format um if
anyone is like
who submitted something way back is
planning on submitting something
again the the submission format is
different now there's
a pitch temp pitch deck template that
you can use um
which is i guess part of helping people
learn how to you know pitch their game
so
you can use that um to pitch your game
and
yeah um look forward to seeing more more
submissions
yeah thank you so much cj for joining us
uh how can we find out more about you
how can we follow you
and everything else um twitter
i guess twitter is on twitter at
underscoreladysith
so yeah at underscore lady sith on
twitter
or you can check out um my website where
i'm trying to document a thousand
african women
and their contributions to games which
is prosarion.net
wait you just you'll find that that's
yeah you've got to go back to that yes
because i don't know how much time we
have left but yeah i'm working on an
initiative to document a thousand
african women and their contributions to
games um
because like i like we talked about
earlier it's already so hard to find
um it like you know it's already
so people are so uncomfortable coming
out of there
and saying you know they made these
little games or even they've worked on
this so
i just wanted people to feel more
legitimate about that and off the top of
my head i already know i know at least
100
african women even 200 easily who have
um
contributed to again in some way yeah
you see there are that many
and the thing is they're not documented
so
i want so that's why i started this
initiative
um so you can check it out prosarium.net
like
i've only documented like a few people
so far because
i've been a student until very recently
until the
i finished um my i actually got my
results today so i'm done i'm paused
everything
great um so yeah so now i can focus more
on
these interviews because there are so
many women out there who i want people
to hear more about so many african women
who have contributed to games in various
ways
that i want people to hear about so yeah
definitely please share that on your
on your uh twitter so we can all uh
retweet that because
i think it's important that people know
that women of color in this industry we
want more women of color in this
industry yeah for sure specifically
thank you so much cj uh we appreciate it
thanks for joining us
um and definitely follow her for sure
thank you all right that was though it's
so crazy to to
to hear about like the different
interactions that folks have you know
especially in the um
the african community african developer
community
um we got coming up we got scott
anderson he's on the line um he's from
unity
he's got a lot of depth uh or he's got a
lot of
industry experience he's a vet let's
let's hop on and talk to scott
hey how's it going what is happening man
brother
it's going all right it's going all
right um
yeah it's dude it's it's we were talking
about this for a while it's so awesome
to have you on
yeah yeah it's been a it's been a
conversation
you know um i'm glad to be here
uh you know um i guess i could
start talking a little about my
background like what i do in unity so
at unity i'm a graphics engineer on the
spotlight team which
actually uh ray was on a little bit
earlier and ray is my boss
so ray's the technical director of
spotlight he runs the whole team
actually
so you know we had a we had a little bit
of a unity representation
just kind of by happenstance uh today
um but yeah so i work with uh
the spotlight team in general works with
various uh
aaa partners to kind of highlight the
engine
um and you know uh you know a lot of it
is like unity
doesn't really make games right there's
demos and there are games like things
that are
within unity but unity doesn't really
make games so um
with spotlight we work with partners to
help them finish games
and then we you know try and bring those
features back to unity so everyone can
use them
so yeah it's been great i've been there
about a year
um but yeah i'm kind of here to uh
not just talk about my experience oh go
ahead oh i'm sorry we have like
we advanced warfare up uh try to shed
light on what you've worked on in the
past
uh yeah but that's really cool like
that and you worked at you were at uh
facebook
before yeah so before unity i was at
facebook i worked
um and on oculus
uh on oculus homes specifically um
and i worked on facebook horizon and
there
i actually uh so actually i'm building
two scripting
visual scripting languages but like i i
kind of architected and designed
and wrote a lot of the code for if you
get in the facebook horizon beta
for the visual scripting language uh
there
um and uh
yeah that was that was a good experience
you know like i mean we're going
backwards a little bit
but um you know kind of after
the reason why advanced warfare showed
up is because i worked at sledgehammer
games
uh when i first moved out to the bay
area um
so i worked on advanced warfare and call
of duty world war ii
uh like i i kind of did the shader for
the threat grenade effect
which is why that video showed up um
but then i got really really into vr so
i worked at
phenomena uh for about a year and a half
on a game called luna
um and did a lot of
vr interaction stuff for that like it's
there's kind of a creative mode where
you could place things in that
um and there's the lunar trailer
um and after luna uh
you know i think i think we had a couple
people bring up you know like like i
think it was tony earlier brought up you
know having kids uh
you think about finance a little bit
more and it's like oh well you know
being an indie game developer is great
but you know in the bay area
like if you if you kind of want to make
a little bit more you have to go to tech
so
and i think that was that was a good
opportunity to bridge and detect because
the oculus acquisition
happened pretty recently and like a lot
of tech companies are looking to bring
in
people in vr right um and that's died
off a little bit but like vr is still
growing it's still like you know quest
two has came out recently it's just
phenomenal
yeah yeah so we're gonna find stuff to
play around with in there
yes so so kind of as we know like vr
didn't necessarily
blow up to like smartphone levels in
like two years or something or like you
know
console levels even but like it's it's
becoming a bigger bigger market and i
think you know
and then in the coming years we're going
to see it being a better space for
people to get into
um uh but yeah i was
when i was there and i was building like
a lot of uh
you know visual scripting tools and game
creation tools and
working in unity also i was like you
know maybe i should just go to unity and
work on the engine and like
really that's how it came about yeah
yeah yeah yeah for
for a couple different reasons so um i
remember when you were trying to work
out this problem
uh and maybe i'm wrong but you're trying
to figure out how to fold
space so you can keep you can infinitely
move in this in this particular
room and you were explaining how that
works was that
am i imagining things or did was that
something that you no no that's
that's that's definitely i like i didn't
actually work on that too much
like uh there's a there's a thing called
redirected walking
right where and some games actually use
it there are some shipping vr games out
there that use it the problem is you
need a little bit
larger space than a lot of people
actually ended up playing vr in
um yeah so uh
and like off the top of my head i can't
think of the games that actually shift
with it but
you can basically do a thing where you
like walk down a corner
um and walk into a new room
and then butcher the the game directs
you to basically walk in circles but it
feels like you're walking through a much
bigger space because you're like walking
around corners consistently
uh and the bigger the space you have the
better of a feeling you can do so like
like if you look at the void you know
like the star wars experience and some
of the bigger
location based things that were actually
doing pretty well before kobe
got kind of killed off by covet
unfortunately
they used that trick a lot too because
they had basically kind of like uh
you know garage size space or whatever
shuffle a couple players through that
space uh you know a paintball arena
size space shuffle a couple players
through that space but they wanted to
feel like a much bigger space so they
would
date you with doors and stuff and have
you turn corners and walk kind of in
these circles but it felt like you were
walking through a larger level
so yeah that's definitely a thing um
yeah where do you see like where do you
want to see games go
now um as far as like the stuff that
you're involved in
at sort of the next level of like
development do you want to see happen
it's a good question i mean i think
uh like what i want to see in general is
i want to see the accessibility of game
development
increase even more right and like you
know we've talked a lot about
different game engines you know here
that how like people can make games part
time as hobbyists right
and they can be like very extremely
impressive you know
fully featured funded commercial games
right like
um you know so we talked about unity we
talked about uh unreal we talked about
rpg maker
we talked about all these accessible
tools and there's new stuff
that's come out recently like dreams and
then let's push it even further right
um but i think we can go even further
than that right like a lot of the
the level of accessibility like you
can't
like it's hard to as a hobbyist that's
you know a skilled artist
to just sit down and build a game still
right it's a lot easier than it than it
was back in the day
uh definitely back when i started
definitely back when tony or ray started
right but like
yeah you know you can imagine you can
extrapolate that out like you know 10 15
years in the future where you have ai
that can build stuff for you or you have
like massive
asset libraries where you know you can
still
make something that looks great um uh
without being able to touch the art
right like everyone kind of brought up
like there are a lot of people who
have a wide variety of skills and design
and programming and art
but they always have like a weak spot
right like oh i can't do animation i
can't
i'm not really good at art like uh
you know i don't like to do personally
don't like to do level design so it's
like oh when i do a prototype or
something
it's like i push myself toward games and
don't do level design
but it's like oh well you know if you
have uh tools that can assist you with
that right like and obviously there are
other ways to do that right like
there's there's a reason why games are
made in teams for the most part like
you know almost every commercial game
especially successful one is made in a
team
but even then like your team might have
gaps or your team might have things that
like
you need help with right so like i think
increasing the accessibility like
reducing
the complexity of programming um
you know uh even like in unity i'm
working on uh
dots a lot which is a data oriented tech
stack right
um and it doesn't necessarily improve
accessibility
and the access of like making it easier
to script games for people
but i think it improves accessibly
greatly in the sense of like
it makes it a lot easier for people to
make very high performance games
that have programming experience in a
way that would be
very hard or impossible before right
so yeah i mean i think i think
increasing accessibility
and that's happening through through
game engines right now it'll happen
through
uh you know kind of like
games like roblox and like you know kind
of these online metaverse
type things like facebook verizon right
so
we're gonna see it but yeah yeah modding
community type stuff but more accessible
than traditional modding right like
yeah for sure so so yeah i'd really like
to see a platform where just like anyone
who felt like they wanted to make a game
like regardless of skill level can do it
and you know there are things where you
you can do that now right like
anyone could probably get twine and make
a game in twine
right uh anyone could probably make a
level in mario maker um yeah
but like you know i want to see like
both the
the ease the ease of use and the depth
of titles being able to build with those
type of things right so
yeah that's that's kind of what i'm
excited about what kind of challenges or
have you had any challenges as a black
engineer or developer uh have you faced
i i got to throw that in there you know
me
uh yeah i mean there's definitely like
like i think
um you know i and we went back to like
me
being at like sledgehammer games and
being an oculus and being at these
different places right and unity and
phenomena
but like uh before that um you know i
started a studio
um called enemy airship uh for a title
called shadow physics right
and shadow physics never shipped but it
was like one of the first nd funded
titles like
um you know i was i was i think the only
black person with on-screen time at all
in indie game the movie right like the
special edition
developer right interviews right and i
think i was the only one
and like there was a lot of like where
that was filmed at tig jam and there was
just a lot of things going on that were
like
problematic to say at least right like
and just being in that space and being
one of the few like
i think myself and like tyrique plumber
back in those days were some of the few
people like take jam and stuff and i
know you've
been in any space really early on but
like
especially early days now i think
there's a lot more people and it's a lot
more mixed or comfortable in the space
but especially early days like it was
kind of a trap like in a lot of ways
we're like
it was like a magnetism when you saw
someone
who was black yeah just so you could
relate i remember
i think i called you tyrique at one
point and i felt like
a racist for some reason yeah
things like that would happen i was
called like token
like straight up by people like i don't
know man there's a lot of a lot of
a lot of stuff like that like i don't
want to get into it too much yeah
yeah we don't need to but like i think
that was one of the challenges right
like
like definitely funding was a challenge
right where i co-founded
uh enemy airship with uh uh
a white co-founder right and like it's
interesting because the game was his
idea but it was entirely my
implementation like i started it i was
the initial i wrote the initial
prototype by myself right
and then i brought him on board to
because like like i said i don't like to
do level design so i was like oh yeah
you're a designer can you do level
design
and it's like cool and we kind of work
that way right um
and i think uh you know it was tony who
said like uh earlier who said like
design
was was kind of uh you know or or
ideas not design ideas were like a dime
a dozen right so like yeah the idea is
cool but a lot of people had that idea
right and like
this is and there have been a lot of
shadow games there are a lot of shadow
games still coming out like uh shady
part of me just ships
there's a game called uh in my shadow
that is like
i feel like kind of captures that shadow
physics spirit in a lot of ways um
and the way it works so um
you know and there were ones before like
contrast came out like
yeah before like you know around the
same time shadow physics was was being
made it was being made so
um but uh yeah it was challenging
because like
having and you hear about this in in
like vc and tech and stuff like that
right but like for me
um you know it wasn't just
just like race in this case it was like
also me being like more junior in the
industry
back in the day back in those days right
this was like 12 years ago at this point
um uh but yeah it was challenging having
like
uh you know being in situations where
you know you're getting funded and like
you're a co-founder but you're not
necessarily you don't fully have a seat
at the table you're kind of halfway in
the room right so
like that was that was definitely a
challenge in this scenario you were
you built the game most of the the game
yeah yeah brought in a co-founder to
help you
you know with level design yeah and some
like vc pitch stuff
but you weren't allowed to sort of have
a
say in the direction of where it was
yeah there was
yeah yeah i mean i i did have a say i
shouldn't say i had no say um
uh that's not true at all but like they
were definitely
strange power dynamics
and stuff yeah there's like i i totally
get it there's like some undercurrent
stuff it's not always blatant
like i'll just i'll just be honest too
even with the mix there'll be certain uh
you know times where i'll be in a
meeting
and because i'm the i look like a young
dude i'm like pushing 40
but they will not look at me they will
look at the other person in the room
and i won't even and i'm like yo this is
my this is actually my [ __ ] decision
you know what i mean so you should
actually pay attention to what i'm
saying too
and and so i get defensive in that
standpoint
and sometimes it's nothing wrong but
it's just because i've had that built up
you know uh those scenarios build up so
much that everything
i start taking defensively you know what
i mean and that's just because of yeah
a reoccurring theme that that happens um
yeah yeah yeah and it's a challenge and
you know you hear about it a lot but i
think i feel like that's one of the more
challenging things it's happened to me
in workplaces as well right um
so it's not just like you know regarding
funding or whatever but yeah yeah it's
definitely a challenge and also like you
you mentioned like young looking right
and like pushing forward
i think we're like both in the same boat
or like a lot of people think i'm
younger than i am i'm not a senior you
know i've been here for 15 years
you know what i'm saying like you were
saying i really appreciate that too
you're saying like i wasn't there
you just need to like whiten the hair on
your face yeah i need to whiten the hair
on my face and just
like put my face in the sun
for no reason you know get wrinkled up
real quick but
uh so what advice you give sort of new
developers
into industry i mean obviously you know
we're focusing on black developers you
know
trying to get into this industry so like
what would you sort of
things that you ran into or like
stumbling blocks for you
you were saying all right this is the
things you need to do in order to like
make it in order to like really
get a foothold in this industry
i mean you know it's like
obviously your your your skills and your
knowledge need to be
like both
you need to be able to demonstrate them
to people right so
like you know obviously i'm i'm
primarily an engineer right so i'm gonna
come and say like you know you just need
to have like
decent computer science fundamentals
depending on what your specialty and
what your area is you need to
like know some of that
regarding gaming right like i think i
think now there's probably a much better
path to just be kind of like if you're a
good programmer to just be like a
a good generalist gameplay programmer
and not really
go super deep in graphics or animation
or anything like that but like
it helps to be deep in at least one
field and like
you know uh know how like directx or
opengl or some like low-level
gpu engine assuming graphics actually
works right know how to build a
physically based renderer from a
basic standpoint right just have those
those fundamentals down right
um uh but you know kind of after that
right after after oh i can demonstrate
my skills
which means building portfolio piece if
you're an artist on building a small
game
honestly i'd recommend everyone to build
a small game especially nowadays like
just just do it
like do it with a small team do it by
yourself doesn't matter just do it right
because if you want to get in games like
just make games like find a way to do it
yeah you know free time as a hobbyist
yeah but uh like
if you want to get a job in the industry
a lot of time you need to go beyond that
and demonstrate like you're
a special decent specialist and can fit
into a role that they have
on their their you know website or
whatever um
but but like you know
beyond being able to demonstrate your
skills networking is extremely
important because if no one knows you in
this industry
yeah other people have brought up like
it's kind of insular right and it's like
but at the same time people are looking
for people black
right now so if you're black
specifically right like
um and you can demonstrate like reach
out to
myself reach out to justin reach out to
ray reach out to the people you see
right and like
i believe people will be helpful um
you know i try and help it i try and
help you know anyone and
it's not like i just want to help like
black
people or anyone right like i tr or
marginalized people or
underrepresented people i try and help
anyone that that you know will reach out
to me and
you know seems you know that they have
something to offer
uh because you never know where people
are gonna be and and you know where
people wanna go
right um but yeah definitely reach out
go to events if you can especially
during covet like a lot of events are
online so you don't
like before there was a barrier to
travel there was a barrier you know you
going gdc was expensive for people they
couldn't get there right like
but now like a lot of events are very
cheap like
five or ten dollars or just free to go
to right
and you can network you can you can get
on a zoom and talk to people and like
everyone's in the room right like
um so you know i i just recommend like
network as much as you can like you know
if you're if you're
of the right age like if you're high
school or college age like
i recommend getting involved with game
heads or a program like that because
then that
that's automatic access to industry
mentors right and like
people at the top level the industry
like have been doing it for a long time
right
like so and it's not just that they're
gonna or
and i'm a game headset myself so i just
say we but uh
it's not that we're just gonna um you
know kind of
guide you of like around how to make
games and stuff but people are
actually gonna like when they know you
they can think about
oh i have this internship where i have
this junior role
that's opened up who do i know that i
want to reach out to
and refer right like yeah
they're going to think about you they're
not going to think about someone that
they don't know because they don't know
them
yeah so i'm just going to jump in
because like um
with alfonso's son joe like i have
played his game at game heads
uh at the the game head showcase and i
loved it immediately and i was like how
can i help
and then you know i played it more and
then i was like how can i plug him in
this place you know with the mix and who
do i know like at you know
uh at microsoft and that type of thing
and that's
what what we need you know in general so
that's like that's some super good
advice
that's it's an amazing thing i think the
thing that folks don't understand is
there's some statistics that like
86 percent of all jobs are through
personal networks
or there are field across all
industries so it's like if that means
only 14
of the jobs are like available for you
to directly apply everything else is
based on
a network and if you are a marginalized
community you don't have access to that
larger network so
we have to actually purposely connect
with one another in this industry
yeah support one another so
yeah for sure that's that's definitely
true in
the game industry so um you know i don't
i don't know the exact statistics or
anything
but i can tell you from like anecdotally
from experience
that like it's much easier to get a job
if you know somebody
than it is if you just go blind like i
think you know i've applied to a lot of
jobs and i think there have been maybe
one or two jobs or even got a callback
where i just did a blind apply on the
website
like period and there was one where i
got an offer
where i did a blind apply and that's
when i had in like industry experience
uh and i just like did a blind apply on
linkedin and they happened to interview
me and
give me an offer um but every other job
except like really early like my first
job which was uh
uh worked on a stargate mmo my first
industry job not my first
game because i i like
early on in college and like out of
college i did indie games part time and
i shipped a couple games
so that's kind of our polio piece yeah i
worked on stargate
stargate worlds back in the day which
actually like a lot of people a decent
amount of people played because they
went into uh
um it went into alpha
um you know open alpha right so they're
like
2 000 players or something right and
like you know i worked on uh
did like animation and abilities kind of
programming stuff for the most part
uh you know it's a little bit of graphic
stuff and some other random things but
yeah um you know it did it didn't ship
like i
have yet to ship an mmo and i've worked
on two of them
oh i worked on um 38 studios uh project
uh copernicus which is like the kingdoms
of amalor
mmo that burned up in a flames
yeah because of rhode island government
and like her chilling
and like all that political maneuvering
stuff but
yeah i worked on that also and i didn't
that's how long did you work on it
i was only i wasn't even there a year
before it shut down
yeah so yeah
yeah i know that that happens a lot you
we appreciate you
so much joining us scott um and where
can we find out more about you
um and what you got going on
oh yeah it's probably best to follow me
on twitter uh
this is my twitter handles there it's uh
at impossiblescott
um yeah usually i'll i'll keep abreast
like if you want to
look up uh you know scott anderson on
linkedin or something
follow me on linkedin that's also works
for more professional connections but
i think twitter is probably the best uh
right now
yeah definitely hit up scott he's got a
wealth of information vet in the
industry if you ever
need to try to connect with build your
network you know now i'm blasting you
out all these people going to hit you up
whatever i want to get my follower
account up so that's cool yeah
sure yeah well uh thank you so much for
joining us it's been a pleasure
appreciate you yeah it was great thanks
for having me guys
cool all right talk to you later okay up
next we got charles
mcgregor uh with hyper dot
check out the trailer
[Music]
so
and that was the trailer for hyper dot i
i was playing it last
uh night on xbox game pass the game is
super fun alfonzo will be driving
um we have charles mcgregor on the line
what's up charles
hey how's it going great great i love
your setup as always
i mentioned that before last time i uh i
saw it
oh thank you so much yeah i uh i
realized that like
it's a little bit on the overkill side
but i just really like like production
and producing and stuff so
yeah i'm into this kind of thing yeah
yeah i yo i was playing hyperdyne i've
played it before
uh i was having a it's it's just so
elegant it's a gorgeous game
it's freaking amazing i know i'm blowing
you up right now
oh thank you so much it's like one of
the most elegant games i've played in a
while
and just like just figuring out the
patterns and that type of thing can you
can you like i mean first give an
introductory uh
introduction to yourself and and your
rich history in
uh game industry sure um so
yeah my uh i guess i'm charles mcgregor
uh i
am the founder of tribe games uh which
is
a a company based out here in minnesota
i am actually the sole
person in uh tribe games um but uh yeah
so i've been making video games since
i was around eight years old um
but uh i have been doing it more in a
professional light since uh
five years ago um but yeah so you at any
at any time you
you're working on multiple projects huh
oh yeah i'm working on
way too many projects at the same time
like
uh currently i'm working on a hyper dot
i got some cool stuff in
in store for people and then uh i'm also
working on
a totally reliable delivery service uh
which is also a local
uh company based in minnesota uh we're
five games
uh and so i've been doing that if you
played the
halloween update to that i was the ghost
i'm also sorry for the ghost everybody
everybody loved the ghost i don't know
what you're talking about
oh but yeah that that's dope tell us
about hyper dot like how did you get
that
started and like can you tell us a
little bit about a bit about the
background
sure uh so with uh hyper dot it
originally started out as
a uh a presentation in a class that had
nothing to do with video games
um they said no powerpoint so i was like
okay fine i'll make a game instead
um originally was just uh it was about
anti-piracy techniques in video games so
uh things like things like drm
and uh or like other attack uh
techniques that you can do so like
there's like nintendo
infamously made a pirated version of uh
earthbound and then put that out on the
market
so that whenever somebody picked it up
they get that special version that
like was extremely hard uh and then when
you got to the very
if you for some uh way got to the very
end of that game
uh it would freeze right at the end of
the uh
as soon as you do the final blow and
then wipe your save
um so there was a lot of like
a lot of uh fun fun things uh that
people had there's also been other uh
examples of anti-privacy techniques of
like just being like hey
i you know like hanging out in a like
in a spot where uh people might be
getting like some type of like malicious
downloading things
and like showing up uh i believe it was
hotline miami
did this where they were just like hey
please don't just randomly download
things just ask me for a key i'll just
give you a key i don't want you to
have like a negative experience
associated with hotline miami
uh and stuff so there's tons of
techniques about that
um and while i've said all of this
uh this is clearly related to hyperdot
um
uh so originally it was just you were
uh the dot was the game
and then all the enemies that show up
are the pirates
and then you're supposed to uh there was
a normal mode where you had
piracy protection so there was it was
not as hard
um and then there was hard mode where
you didn't so then everything showed up
right away and you would like
almost instantiate well not almost
instantaneously lose but uh it would be
way harder to survive um again
totally reaching that class had nothing
to do with video games
that is so interesting for sure i didn't
even catch that
like metaphor there at all obviously oh
yeah
so that's such a cool background yeah
yeah
that really just as soon as that class
was over it was like i had four days to
finish it
as soon as it was over i showed at a
local event
uh and then uh people encouraged me to
hey you should continue working on this
and i
i also really enjoy working out like i
was finding myself
playing the game i was like oh i need to
test something and then 15 minutes later
i was like oh wait i was supposed to
test something
so so there was a lot of that um but
i was encouraged to work on it and the
second i said yeah i'm gonna work on
this more
i just totally ditched the uh
anti-pharmacy origins
uh although for like two
years two and a half years it was called
that because i couldn't come up with a
good eye
name idea uh it's called anti-piracy
it was called anti-piracy so if you see
tweets from me
uh three or four years ago i might be
referring to it as anti-piracy
and that is that is so no
yeah it has that feel like when i was
playing it uh before and i was
last night i just got caught we because
we did our other stream yesterday
and i just wanted to relax and chill i'm
like should i boot it up on my pc
or should i just lay out my bed like
this
oh yeah like a little kid and just like
play it and then i had to sit up
i was like i gotta pay attention hold on
one sec
yeah i mean but uh it's so interesting
like the the different uh mechanics um
like you have the one i don't remember
all the names but there's the one like
this one right here
where it just feels like traffic you
know and you're trying to get through it
that's how i felt it's like
oh yeah like you're in yeah yeah or
you're like
in tokyo and you're walking down the
streets in shibuya and you don't want to
bump into anyone or new york
punch in the face yeah uh this is
actually one of my favorite
uh modes of dark mode uh where yeah
you can't see everything around you i
guess i never actually did the spiel
uh i guess i'll i'll i can do the spiel
real quick
yes please hyperdot is a action arcade
game where you dodge
everything um so yeah you play as a dot
and you have to
avoid all of the different uh shapes
that show up so
um and there's these things called
modifiers which change the way the
game's played
uh like this this is dark mode where you
can't see everything
we got uh player changing the player's
size changing the
the arena size um or you can also
change the mode so there are some modes
where you want to collect things
uh and not just dodge stuff oh geez man
yeah this is
also the game is a little challenging
just a slightly
bit it's all fun
oh yeah you got this
this guy not moved so fast that's my so
there's a hundred there's
there's over 100 levels right yes uh so
yeah there's over 100 levels in the game
um i i mistakenly when i first
started the game after i did the four
day of
being doing a prototype um i was like oh
yeah i'm gonna make
a hundred levels no problem and i
thought it would be done in
one summer like yeah i got this it took
me four years
so okay so yeah
it wasn't uh it wasn't as easy as i
thought uh
but uh that's that's what a scope you
can do but
uh i'm super proud of all the hey you
got this um i'm super proud of all of
the
the different levels and mechanics and
there are the ways that i
manipulate the the small set of things
uh in the game and like that's that's
really what the like essence of the game
is
is like i had two core principles of
like minimalism and flexibility
uh and the minimalism was like i just
want to have it so that the only thing
you do in this game
is move uh and then how can i like
mess around with that so yeah yeah that
was a lot of fun trying to explore and
figure out
all that stuff it just you know took me
a little longer yeah it feels like a
bull
it i love it because it reminds me of
bullet hell shooters the dodging
involved with like ikaru
or raygun you know like uh r-type that
type of thing and i love that
maneuverability there's one
in particular where i had to just keep
rotating my little dude oh it was the
ice one there's an ice wall yes yeah and
i was and you have this little circle
you have to stay in so i was just like
i found this little technique where i
had to go in circles to dodge everything
around the other circle and it just like
the creativity that you have to use in
order to beat the levels is cool
you know yeah no it and that's also
one of the things i've i find like a ton
of different inspiration from a ton of
different places
um and like uh like ikaruga style games
and or like yeah our type and stuff
totally inspire inspiration a lot of
inspiration from like super hexagon
and uh in geometry wars and also
like the visual style and
uh and also like the the level like
how i set up levels and things of like n
plus plus
uh those kind of things i'm just i'd
adore
uh that kind of style so i i wanted to
try my hand at it
i like the level creation that you have
that as a part of it like
people can build their own levels that's
really uh yeah
that that actually was when i when i
mistakenly said yeah this will only take
one uh one summer i was like i didn't
actually i had no plans on having a
level editor
um but after making the first level by
hand where i had to like
put in each value be like all right
press the button
and be like oh is this working uh and
and what not
that kind of or like and then waiting
and loading and whatnot that kind of
back and forth didn't it was not uh
super fast
um so i was like oh i should probably
make a uh
an editor this was tough for sure
there's different feels to every level
and yeah some i'm not good at but i've
seen
i've seen that you're better at some of
the ones that i'm not good at
also uh thanks uh hey dmarc in the chat
i'm gonna head to the music yeah i'm
super proud of the music
uh in particular this oh song but yeah
so did you do did you also compose the
music like
i know you yeah this is your game so you
did pretty much everything right
yeah so yeah i did all the art music
programming design
uh and stuff um for the longest time
there was only one song in the game
uh and that wasn't until like maybe the
last
six months of development where there
was a second song that actually showed
up so yeah
wow yeah the presentation is super clean
and seamless that's one thing that i
feel so you like catch that vibe
if you want to stay in this kind of
world you know what i mean you're just
like oh yeah
just continuously doing that and that's
like yeah i definitely didn't want to
have it so that was like super abrasive
and
like in your face uh because this game
is already
a slight bit stressful if you're trying
to trying to survive
i'm not stressed
and i know it's not mobile game-esque
but it has that kind of feel is the bar
because you're like four out of six i
just got
two i was so close yeah that that was
fun trying to find that oh
what what'd you say oh it was that's
really fun trying to find that balance
of like oh i'm just so close being able
to get that that's where you get that
super satisfying like yes i find it yeah
yeah
last night i had to tell myself like yo
i i'm not a one more
you know you know one more uh what no
for real though
yeah yeah this is actually the one that
one didn't count i only lasted like
five seconds let's get like a real true
one in yeah i
i know that feeling that's really that's
really cool
so you're so now you're uh you're
working on some other
some other games um what are some of
your other previous uh
indie titles that you worked on sure uh
so
my very first uh like fully released
game
uh is called glitch in the system uh it
was
very much uh inspired like in a geometry
wars thing
kind of also in similar time constraints
where i only had like two days to
make the original prototype but uh uh so
that
is unfortunately not actually available
uh but wink wink maybe it will be
soon on other uh platforms it might oh
that's somewhere here quick um uh
but yeah so that that uh that was like
my first fully released game and that's
really where uh like things like come on
took a change it took a change in my
feeling
this is great yeah
you ask questions there you go
watch i'm gonna die i'm like over there
oh yeah yeah see you
oh this is the sliding one yeah okay
this was rough i was fronting like i'm
you know i mean like i can make this
happen
but maybe i can't see you no you got
this
let's see see my little take my little
jiggle technique there you go
see a little jiggle you got a little oh
schnooks
oh you see that you good see look at
that no problem
all right all right well matt props
yeah that was that one was is pretty
tough and that
to be honest that uh thumb stick i'm
gonna give you give you up on that one
because that one's a little
shady do you like give me you gotta set
up you give me any booty equipment yeah
yeah you set me up on on a live stream
homie
yeah you guys you got set up on that one
with that thumbstick dude like we gotta
we gotta
go with first party next time
extra shady give them yeah give them
that the third party controller they're
like yeah that's
been used a little too much yeah yeah
like you can't yeah you know like for
regular games you could this one has
like
i don't know there's some dirt in the
you can't do that with your game
it's not yeah no okay
yeah actually that uh speaking of
controllers
um it's that segway is um the games
actually
uh supports a wide variety of
controllers so um if you get it on like
steam or something
you can actually play using uh eye
tracking the tobii eye tracker
wait
uh some one of my friends was joking
like oh man you should get
hyper not to work with uh uh toby eye
tracker and i was like ah
that's that's funny yeah that'd be
really interesting and then like after
we laughed for like two minutes or
something i was like huh maybe i should
maybe i should try that and then uh then
actually i was like three hours later
super huge credit to like the toby eye
tracking
api and stuff i was able to get eye
tracking in the game and then had a
bunch of people testing
wow it was a awesome oh yeah it's a
uh really cool experience to go through
um and it was
at that point where uh go where i was
like oh yeah this will be
this will be a feels like a bubble dude
i'm clowning you this time bro stay in
the bubble dude it says stay
just kidding but uh that was that was uh
that was something where i uh shifted
one i thought that would be like
oh this would be a novel thing uh
because that's where it started out
from but then i thought of like oh what
if if you don't have
uh if you have like a motor disability
or you can't like hold a traditional
controller you could play
you could theoretically play hyperdot
using just your eyes
and um and actually i was able to
witness somebody play through
every single level inside a hyperdot uh
from start to finish using just the
tobii eye tracker and it it's just like
one of the most like heartwarming i
can't believe that that's
amazing possible wait what other
interesting controls did you adapt for
for the game
sure um so uh there's the microsoft
adaptive controller while
of course uh the adapter controller
works with uh basically with every game
um i did put in some stuff like with
that in mind
to make sure that like oh yeah this is
designed with it uh in mind and stuff so
like you can plug in uh we used a
foot controller at a convention once
where we had like you can play hyper dot
just using your feet
um which was a lot like super cool and
you can also um
there were like sometimes where we could
bring up the foot controller and then
you can
like lean on it and use your arms back
and forth it's talking about
like the tilt thing yeah the tilt thing
yeah yeah the
3d rudder foot controller that thing did
you
did you get an advanced copy of like the
the um what is it called the heartbeat
monitor
oh no it came out
don't give me that idea no i'm just
kidding um but yeah
that like
yeah be like and then you you just
avoid all the things
hyperventilating it's just
this game has killed seven people
[Music]
but um but yeah so like that is one if
uh i wanted like i'm interested in like
supporting
a lot of even i guess not necessarily
like mainstream uh controller stuff or
like uh
alternate controller uh and things so
like yeah like the microsoft adapter
controller toby eye tracker is one
um i wanted to make it so that like oh
yeah i'm playing on steam and
if i plug in my ps4 controller i want to
have it work and show the ps4 controls i
was like yeah no problem
oh i'm on a switch yeah i'll use the joy
con stuff
like i want to have it so that the game
meets you where you're at
uh rather than you having to be like oh
man i have to plug or use joy to key
uh and stuff like that i'm gonna have to
try to try it on a fight stick
i think that'd be right oh yeah that
would be awesome
yeah i think that like you know arcade
kind of feel
have you ever tried to have it in a
cabinet that would be kind of sick
yeah so uh so my publisher glitch um
before we were actually like we
partnered and did a publisher developer
thing
um we actually had uh glitch had like
these things called arcade backpacks
where we were able to put in a
laptop and on a backpack and then we had
like an arcade stick
um and stuff and then we would rock
around uh like conventions and things
and then people would be able to play
uh hyperdot or anti-piracy at the time
um uh and they were able to play using
like the arcade things
then we were like hey you wanna you want
to play a game and then we just like
walk up be like oh yeah here you go and
then they would be able to
sit there and and try dodging uh
dodging all the things on the back of uh
somebody being like yeah way to go
did you did you at e3
at indycade uh we didn't have it at e3
um but we oh man i forget where uh we
had it
it was a it was one of like one of the
early versions of
anti-piracy um so so uh that's that's
largely
uh why but it's all it's like i really
do enjoy like
exploring a lot of that kind of uh space
and things like that
but yeah i'm gonna have a broken tv
i'm just letting you know right now oh
you're okay you're in this way
you did one of these before stay in the
circle scenarios
trying to use your trick oh you're on a
slide one okay yeah this is
you gotta that stuff is terrible you
really need to
compensate for that stick dude like yeah
this level is trying to just break down
that would be super hard to use a d-pad
yeah that ain't working oh
my god definitely you can also you can
also try and using the right stick
uh that also works uh to move around
that actually
yeah you put your left hand on the right
stick that may help you oh
but um yeah so
so you said you have you have or am i
mistaken you have an update for this
game
yes uh so i've been working on the
biggest update that i've uh put out so
uh before i put out gauntlet mode which
is basically the
uh single-player campaign but you have a
limited set of lives
so you can have either a hundred fifty
ten or one life and you're trying to see
how far you can get into the game
uh and that was the the biggest update
then
and now i'm working on an even bigger
update
that i'm not ready to devolve all the
information but
you can expect um a lot more uh stuff
that you'd be able to
play and mess around it um but yeah
that's it's taking me a little bit
longer
um because uh unfortunately the pandemic
has happened
and it's harder to get people to be able
to test
and get proper testing and things like
that because i don't wanna i don't wanna
have it so that like the game is uh
or the new stuff is uh unbalanced and
things like that but uh uh hopefully
soon tm uh to be out there
yeah so like i'm just curious too on
totally uh
reliable delivery service what role do
you play on
on that team sure uh so i'm
i guess i consider myself more of like a
generalist
uh well which would make sense because i
like to do a lot of different things
but um on that team we're working on uh
working on the steam release so we're
working on doing the um
working on largely doing like uh uh
overhaul on a lot of
different things uh and features i'm
doing a lot of the ui
stuff so um when you when you see the
final product
um all the cool animations and and ui
things and uh a lot of that stuff that
would be me that's
uh working on that stuff that's dope and
the minnesota area i was talking with
uh with ty uh and in the minnesota area
i was talking with uh zach from space
space mace like yeah such a rich
community in minnesota can you talk a
little bit about that because i don't
think people know that that's on the map
dope game sure in studios for sure yeah
uh so
speaking of zack from space mace i
actually work with zach
from space mace uh on totally reliable
delivery service we both are
working on it it's been awesome um but
uh the minnesota
scene uh it definitely like especially
within like the last
five years uh it went from a lot of
small indie developers like uh not
necessarily centralized
um but like being like oh yeah i hope
one day that i'll be able to
finally finish this game and put it out
on itch
to like two
but it went from that to like oh yeah
we're trying to get this thing out on
like steam ps4
xbox and yeah we're working trying to
get these deals and it's like
it's it's like so uh heartwarming and
amazing to see
uh that this community has like has
grown and matured
uh enough to be able to to even like
consider those ideas because yeah that
was definitely
not on uh like the radar for a lot of
people we were just
we were just trying to trying to finish
a product
um yeah like but yeah it's been it's
been awesome and the community is great
um being able to uh work together and
hang out well
in pre-pandemic times being able to hang
out and uh like play tests and going to
conventions and stuff is
super great and a lot of uh a lot of
indie teams working out here
and then we also have a couple of uh
medium-sized
companies out here as well the bat was
uh
the the new battle toads game was that
on was that
is that there too that team ah i don't
know oh man that would be great if i
know it's just that's fine yeah
like hey i'm trying to take a deep dive
there so
where can we find a hyper dot i know
it's on xbox game pass
or is it everywhere right now i know
it's on steam too
yeah so uh you can find uh hyperdot on
itch and steam with uh pc mac and linux
uh you can find it on xbox and xbox game
pass it is play anywhere
so you can play it on your pc or on the
xbox one or xbox
that janky
there you go um and then uh i am
uh i might be working on other things i
don't know
maybe you can't announce anything yet
i can't announce anything i can't wait
to see
what here what you got going next
man you got to switch it to a two shot
there you go yeah yeah yeah
he got to level 18 um but yeah could you
can you give some advice to
up-and-coming game developers
for for make either getting into the
industry itself
or starting off their own teams sure
um so the the one that i normally say
is uh just start uh working start
making a thing start doing it and start
out super small um
i think that that is super useful and
it's really it's really helpful to
be able to be like okay i find i made
something
and that really was when like things
shifted for me uh like i mentioned i've
been making games since i was eight but
i didn't finish
a game until i was in college
of uh it was my sophomore year of
college um
and that like that was like a huge shift
in like how i perceived like oh that's
what the end of a game looks like
um it wasn't just like a amorphous oh
man that just seems so hard to do
um but like really like paring down and
like making it super small
uh was super helpful but um i also do
want to say because
a lot of people will say that and it's
super useful advice um
but it's hard to like act on it was like
oh yeah we'll make a game
okay fine uh so i would actually like
recommend
look at a uh a classic game like some
like an arcade classic or or something
that's like
something that you enjoy like let's say
you really enjoyed uh pac-man
or or something like that or dig dug um
i would say look at that
and then figure out well how do i make
uh how do i make a dig dug
uh in 2021 or like how do i make
uh a dig dug uh with this cool
like interesting twist but like only
have it
be that one level like arcade level
uh that way then you will have the scope
is already there you know the ending
because you see what dig dug looks like
you can bring that over and you can be
like okay
well this is what dig dug looks like and
i just want to have it so that
it's set in space or uh it is
uh you have it so that you have to like
climb your way up
rather than dig down um so like
uh have that one like twist or something
that'll that'll help help
uh establish your style slash
uh give you like some type of interest
in it
and then try and complete that and that
way you're able to actually again
see oh this is what an ending of a game
looks like like
completing a game playing a game is the
best yeah i agree finish something
i think yeah finishing something so yes
finishing something like just from
again from my personal experience it's
like i'm gonna make this game in two
years
five years yeah oh yep
yeah oh yeah it's only gonna take me the
summer four years later and then
yeah we we recently developed because
we're doing the
you know the jane scion bob games last
year in between that
the chronic punch game uh we did the
mall brawl nintendo game and within that
like within a year we developed from
start to finish
uh and released the game and it was just
so gratifying after spending
like five years four years on chronic
blunt punch due to like everything that
happens you know like
getting new people for the team or like
lack of funding or whatever
just to be able to make something small
but it's still great is gratifying so i
would say like
finish yeah finish something finishing
yeah
that's another theme that that it just
jumps around throughout this whole
uh this whole showcase is um you know
makes things just make just start making
things but what you said
was make something small is
super key when you're when you're
starting yeah super key
try doing that if you have if you're
like well but i really want to make this
huge
mmo then try like breaking down that mmo
into smaller games and being like oh
this is what's wrong with trying to do a
huge massively multiplayer online game
for my first game that i've ever worked
on
having it so that it's like a smaller
game that's just a piece
or like a piece of that uh mmo that
you're really wanting to do
um that kind of thing is super useful
uh because you're like oh this is like
you're able to have a complete game a
complete product you
get to the end and then be like oh i've
learned some things about
uh this art style that i wanted to do or
this game mechanic but it's all
condensed inside of this small game
uh so that way you're able to then be
like oh yeah i'll i'll apply this to
this
future big game that i want to do and
then you work on
another part of that future big game
that you want to do inside of its own
game
so you can again you get the
satisfaction of being able to actually
complete
a game uh but then also learn
uh all the different uh the different
mechanics and things or art styles or
music uh and all the different aspects
of it
that you want to do or like if you
wanted to make a small game and then
learn how to like how do i do the
marketing or how
how do i interact with like a publisher
and stuff yeah do those small kind of
things
uh and then you'll be able to build up
and and learn how to do that
that's amazing advice so how can we find
uh out more about hyper dot and what
charles mcgregor is doing
like how can we follow you yeah
my moment um so yeah you can uh either
follow
me at tribe games or me personally at
darkhazetg on twitter
um i guess you can follow you can find
me
also on my website tribe dashgames.com
and then i also have a soundcloud
because people say that at the end of
these things right i have a soundcloud
vibes yes the actually the entire
soundtrack of hyperdot
is available on spotify and steam and
whatnot so you can that's a good yeah
that's a good shot
i am going to find it now personally
awesome selfish
but uh yeah thank you so much for
joining us and and i look forward to
talking to you more amazing game
uh amazingly frustrating as well but i'm
not saying
i'm gonna be it's gonna be on the
console tonight i'm gonna be playing
that and
um it's gonna yeah awesome thanks
thanks for having me yeah thank you so
much yo i am so sorry for setting you up
with that no you gave me sticky stick
like ice skating uphill man what's going
on yeah that was hyper dot uh
charles mcgregor up next we have um
there's you know we we talked about
about the the humble games black game
developer fun we talked about game heads
niantic is really making things happen
with uh
their um black developer initiative
um with their first title uh wicked
saints so we have a trailer going to
drop
for niantic shout out to them and let's
check it out
my name is jessica murray i'm the ceo
and co-founder of wicked saint studios
based in medford oregon but my team is
all over the world literally we make
interactive story games where people can
play the hero and then actually be the
hero in real life
we are going to be building world reborn
on the niantic platform
it's like game of thrones meets
riverdale with a little dash of black
mirror
my path to game design is pretty
atypical
before i was a game designer i was
actually a peace builder
i trained young activists all over the
world in social change communication
we wanted to figure out a way to scale
that change how do we
reach more young people and activate
them in their community
to handle conflict in a constructive way
[Music]
when we had this revelation that young
people wanted to practice
what to do first before being sent out
to do stuff
we started doing interactive story games
using twine
so text-based story games imagine that
you fall into this deep pit and you're
facing a dragon
the world will tell you that you have
two choices you either slay the dragon
or you get eaten by the dragon the
problem with those two choices
is that neither of them gets you out of
that deep dark pit
what we're trying to do is create tools
so that
you don't just survive these situations
but you can fly
we want to create a society of high
functioning dragon riders
[Music]
so much excites me about being able to
work with niantic and this platform
what it's done is it's really kind of
exploded our box there's so much that we
can tap into with ar and geolocation
that we've never had access to before
stories are so powerful
because people's behavior changes
through experiences
with interactive story games you're no
longer having this kind of vicarious
experience
you are the main character i'm so
excited for
niantic's black developer initiative
it's something that's going to expand
universes of stories and experiences
that haven't been tapped into
especially for us we just needed that
shot we needed someone to believe
in our idea we've always been trying to
mobilize young people
to actually go out into the world and
move and do good
who's got people to move better than
niantic
and that was the niantic black game
developer initiative i don't know what
you thought about that i thought it was
dope
i really like the the graphics in that
game yeah it's
it's really cool what they're doing and
all of the supporters and
and speaking of that we want to give a
final shout out
to our sponsors uh starting with
humble games with the humble black game
developer fund
if you're interested in checking it out
check out the link below they've been
amazing sponsors and working with us
and we have another we have more a
plethora of more
sponsors that have worked with us over
the years raw fury
we couldn't have done this without them
uh playstation jumped in
um razer has helped us with hardware
humble games again and of course
kickstarter thank you so much for
supporting us
um we want to thank all the viewers
wilmer sounds av
society of course game heads
and what do you want to say um i just
want to say
if you are a developer of color
especially a black developer please
submit to the humble fund also reach out
to justin and i if you would like to be
you know showcased on this program we're
going to continue to do this
and um there's a lot of opportunity out
here for us but we have to
do it as a community yeah totally that's
what black voices and gaming is about is
connecting to
the community of black developers
showcasing and highlighting
uh black developers and creators and
everything it's been a blast
we appreciate everybody again my name is
justin woodward co-founder
of the media indie exchange the mix and
we are out of here
all right peace
[Music]
you